Calera is on it, man.
She's ready to go.
Whoa!
Okay...
Wait, what?
Wait, I was on it.
They're trying to do...
What's going on?
I won for... oh wait, this is training.
You got first on the training one.
She's not gonna leave now!
She's not gonna leave!
This is insane, dude.
I won the heads or tails!
I didn't win the heads or tails!
Oh sh...
Okay, I could listen to my own stream.
Whoops.
Hey, this is what we'll do.
What?
One more minute, then we gotta get it.
Alright.
Gooby plays modern!
Modern too!
Sorry, caps lock.
I can't believe we started early.
I'm already mentally over.
After heads or tails, I'm already done for the day.
This is a run back, yeah, from the one and done.
Yeah, no, she's gonna one and done.
She apparently requested to one and done me.
Just one and done her again.
Easy.
I don't think I'm allowed to.
I think I might get...
I might get yelled at.
So what you do is you win, and then go back to character select screen.
Oh my god, that's so evil.
I think I'm gonna get kicked out.
Oh, thank god.
Are we just waiting?
For...
Yeah.
I think she's asking for an okay from Sam Jam.
Oh yeah, you can play once...
Wait, they're spectating our match?
This is fucked!
Are we on stream?
Apparently.
Yeah, I think they're gonna put us on the mainstream.
That's fucked.
The war's staving.
I'm really tired.
The coin...
The coin flip!
It was so intense!
She already lost, right?
The coin flip was so intense!
It was the mod.
All those...
She won the coin flip, but it didn't matter at the end of the day.
It was just way too much.
Too much pressure on the heads or tails.
50-50.
Oh shit.
I get player one?
Do I get that side?
Yay!
You lost.
Tough luck.
I think she was talking about...
I'm honoring the first flip!
That's fucking right.
Oh.
That's fucking...
Based mod.
Yeah, right.
Cool.
Let's do it, Doke.
Alright, eat up.
Ugh.
Okay.
You think she'll let me?
Okay, I'm gonna do the knowledge check.
Wait, are you hungover?
You're gonna start with the run?
I'm gonna do the knowledge check.
Oh, I got...
I got some extra money.
You get one every set.
Yeah.
If it works...
You know it's gonna be free.
Let's see.
Nope.
He's using the free...
The free.
It didn't work.
Oh, we're behind.
Oh shit, we caught up.
No, we caught up.
Wow, technology.
We caught up.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, Gumi's a master on wake up.
Oh, she's using the toy.
Guys, I think I messed up with the king thing.
The king thing was definitely not it.
The king thing was not it.
Did I rush in?
She's not gonna be ready for shit.
You gotta block and wake him now.
Okay.
Just block, block, block, block, block.
There you go.
Yep, that's a triangle.
Oh, she did that to me.
Yeah.
Yeah, so she jumped the run grab last round.
So let's do just drive rush something else.
Drive rush something else.
And then time to square.
Okay.
Just block on this one.
What the hell?
She got combos?
Okay.
Oh yeah, get in there.
Okay, don't drive rush her.
Just walk up.
Yeah.
Okay, just block.
Nice!
Oh.
Okay, block it out, block it out.
Okay.
Yeah, just gotta block it out.
Oh.
I can get in.
Yeah, she's gonna do that.
So you remember, if she does that, you can do down triangle from full screen.
Oh, what?
Oh my god.
Okay, just block here.
Yeah, you gotta walk in.
You gotta make a miracle happen.
Oh, she grabbed.
Yeah.
So the only thing is, like, you just gave up too much health too early.
Okay.
Remember when you're walking in, use circle and jump x to walk her down.
Circle and jump x...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, when she...
Is this first a one?
What happened there?
No, that was a one and done.
One and done.
That's fine, that gives me time to talk strax.
So we win?
Yeah.
Yeah, she quit.
Let's go!
Brian, what does she do if...
If Gumi's full screen, it's...
The Blanka ball is coming, right?
You just do Lariat.
Okay.
If you're sitting full screen and she flies at you with the Blanka ball, it's down triangle.
But you're not even in that range right now.
That's not even what's getting you.
It's just up close.
It's kind of a scramble.
Let's try to slow it down.
You can play much better when you're slowing it down.
And let's use the spaced out moves.
And if you knock her down, just don't even approach.
Just let her stand back up.
It's going to match the ball.
Oh, she's going to Blanka ball.
Am I not watching?
Oh my god.
Beat her up!
Oh, I Lariat though.
That was a good try.
Yeah, it's tough.
So just keep trying to get closer.
Nice.
Just block it out, block it out.
That's her command grab.
That you have to jump.
Okay.
Okay, we got to go ham, I think.
I think it's time.
I think it's time to unleash the demons.
Nice.
There you go.
I accidentally used a ball.
You don't need it, you don't need it.
Oh, I don't know.
I feel like I do.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Just block it out and then go ham.
That's fine.
Just block all this.
Yeah, no problem.
Yep, you're good.
Cool.
Keep blocking.
Yeah.
Aw, she jumped.
She might not punish.
Yeah, see?
Aw, she...
Okay, wait.
You have a chance.
Nice.
Get a DI.
Oh, okay.
Let's go!
Alright, comeback time.
Aw.
Nice jump in.
Oh, jeez.
Yeah, jump X might just body hurt.
I'm not going to anti-air you.
Just jump at her with X.
Oh man, lucky.
Yep, there you go.
Exactly.
Block it out, block it out, block it out.
Easy.
Let's go!
Aw, she did her super.
You're still alive.
I think you're going to live though.
You're going to live.
You're going to be close though.
Okay, just got to block.
Nice anti-air.
What?
No!
Oh!
Block, block, block, block, block, block.
Yep, exactly.
She doesn't know how to punish.
She's going to randomly slide, so you need to block her toes.
No, she grabbed.
She grabbed.
I had a feeling she was going to grab too.
But...
That was a really good try.
Yeah, I had a feeling.
Is that it?
That's it, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I felt she was going to grab, but then you were like, block.
So I was like, okay, I'll block.
Yeah, I mean...
She's been grabbing the entire time.
The other thing she does there is the slide.
That's the problem.
So you got to react to the command grab and jump it.
Yeah.
Maybe a bad call.
I didn't think she would do the command grab there.
There's two things she does.
I think she was doing more grabs than slides in general.
Yeah.
Yeah, the slide is like the classic blocker thing.
Yeah, I'm going to remove the body.
I think next time we know that she just does command grab.
We can see it in jump or lariat.
Buffed Gief.
Yeah, honestly, get him in the top five.
I almost forgot I'm on a team with a bunch of degenerate Gief players for a second.
That's awful.
What's the big idea?
Oh no, this guy has sand.
Why do you have to manually spectate?
Holy...
Did the match begin?
It did.
Wait, what?
Yeah, I did click it, but it didn't let me spectate earlier.
Oh, damn.
Yeah, it has to catch up.
Alright, I'm locked in.
What the f...
Oh, okay, I spectated though, so it was like...
It went super speed mode.
Very nice.
Nice.
So good.
Oh, nice.
Oh, yes.
The combos.
Oh, combos, okay.
Oh my god.
You actually know what you're doing.
Holding my breath.
Let's go!
Nice!
You got this, SK.
That was solid.
He's so scared.
Oh.
Yeah, you're about to burn him out.
Oh!
No!
That's the problem.
He's gonna burn you out.
Yeah.
You're good.
He's spending everything.
He has to do this, because...
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
If you believe.
Oh!
You have your level 3.
No!
You got the meter advantage.
Oh!
I'm going to react to one.
Not very good.
Amazing level 3.
Oh, nice.
I love that.
That's perfect.
And it's classic.
It's gonna do so much damage.
Nice.
Yeah, he's just waiting to anti-air.
So we can approach on the ground a lot.
There you go.
That's fine.
Oh, no!
Oh!
That's nice.
You played that really good.
The only thing is, if you go into burnout, just press way less buttons.
Just get your one poke and then block.
But you're playing really good.
There's nothing really I would change about your game plan at all.
You got this.
Wait, what?
Is your match still going, SK?
No, they left.
Yeah.
Sometimes it kicks out just the spectators.
That's why.
Wait, it kicked out BrawlPro.
Yeah, you're the only one that got kicked out.
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
What are you doing over there?
I think Steam just died.
Did Steam die?
It's not maintenance day.
It's Wednesday.
It's on Tuesdays, right?
Yeah, it's Wednesday.
I'm still in here.
Yeah, me too.
This happens to me in ranked a lot.
Is it me?
No, I mean, CFN just is mysterious.
CFN is fun.
What the fuck?
Yeah, the only other thing, SK, is that you can mix in more walk-up throws.
Like in your dry brush pressure, you can dry brush and then walk and throw a little bit more.
I'll restart Steam.
Like crazy.
So, your pressure is really good.
If you throw him a bit more, he's gonna fall apart.
Everything else is perfect though.
Got it.
I'm nervy.
It's alright.
You got this.
Let's go.
Ow.
Round robin one doesn't matter.
Remember.
Ow.
Oh wait, you're fighting.
I didn't even realize it started.
I wasn't spectating.
Nice.
Reversal.
He's catching on to your reversals.
I think just a little bit more blocking on wakeup.
He doesn't throw you ever, so you can just block a little bit more on wakeup.
Man.
Who showed up to the party?
Dude, that's so annoying.
Nice throw.
Very good.
There you go.
Oh.
I fear I'm dead.
It's over.
Yeah.
GG.
Good try.
I saw you went for that level three combo.
Is that what happened earlier?
Yeah.
Yeah, that would have been really sick.
Yeah, if that had landed, you would have been a good spot to win.
But, it was a good try.
You had a good game plan.
Next time.
It's alright.
It's day one.
Day one.
We're sandbagging on purpose so we can analyze the situation.
Right?
That's it, right?
No, I actually agree.
I think there's clear ways to beat these opponents.
Gumi was doing the command grabs.
Just got to figure out the jumps on that.
Ultima was just waiting for DI's.
We just got to throw them a bunch.
There's definitely clear weaknesses we can pick them apart with next time for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think next time instead of a coin flip, it's rock, paper, scissors.
And I had my king mod on and it threw me off.
Yeah, I was playing with the king mod and it literally threw me off.
I thought it was going to be that bad.
I was like, this looks too weird.
I'm not used to it.
Where's the guy?
Who are you playing now, BP?
I'm on Zangief.
No, no, like who are you playing against?
Big Booty Man.
Oh, okay, gotcha, gotcha.
Oh shit, you got the master too.
I just saw.
Oh, you got the master?
Let's go!
He was struggling for that last night, but it came together.
Okay, nice.
Dude, hell yeah, dude.
The grind.
Let's go.
Alright.
You know the 10 match-up, you know what to do.
Brawlhalla, did you create your own club for yourself?
My Discord server.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Oh boy.
Oh wow.
My man's cooking.
Yes, Chef.
He's burnt.
Nice.
S-Band is kind of nutty.
Might be good to let him wake up.
Block and punish.
Nice.
He was ready in the wrong way.
Oh, this sucks!
Oh my goodness.
That hella worked.
Yay!
I like how he breaks the 4th wall for a second and just points at you.
You got it, bro.
Good one.
That's hella cool.
Yeah, you can just...
get an actual speedy on that.
Yeah, trust them.
I think that's one of his tactics.
Chat's telling me.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Oh, he's saving you.
You're good.
I did you a favor.
Ooh, that's a nice Dark Souls dodge.
The invincibility frame.
He won.
He messed up his mash.
But yeah, I think if you approach him, he's going to let it rip like 90% of the time.
he's going to let it rip like 90% of the time.
Ooh.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, that's cool.
I shouldn't have done that, but...
You know what?
Normally I roast you for your meter management, but...
You can roast me.
That was pretty bad.
No, nothing left.
Yeah, that sent a message.
Yeah, he spewed him.
He won't mentally recover from that.
Nice.
Ooh, that was...
I like it.
I like the sequence.
Oh.
Yeah, punishable.
Yep, yep, yep.
Nice.
Oh, level one.
Unsafe.
So unsafe.
Yay!
Let's go.
Please.
And I like your meter management that last round too.
I saw the reset with the knee.
Thanks.
Oh, but you're supposed to sandbag.
What happened?
How do I get out of here?
You're supposed to give up all the data.
How do I leave the first lobby?
What do I do?
You press...
I think you press B, right?
No?
Yeah, back out.
It says leave custom room.
Will that leave, like, the whole lobby?
That'll leave the whole thing.
Yeah, so what do I do?
Maybe go to the...
Maybe go to the actual selection?
What is it?
You can click on the room you're in, and then it lets you leave, I think.
Maybe?
I don't know.
You press X and then choose an option?
I actually don't remember.
Maybe right click?
Select button?
Ah!
It's select.
That's very unorthodox.
That's not very...
It's not very simple.
Alright, more Ken.
More Ken.
Fun.
Oh wait, I don't want to queue up.
Why did I queue up?
Winner plays Doki.
Let me out.
Let's go.
You got this.
What the fuck?
Wait,
who's who?
Oh, you're...
I was like, who am I queueing for?
Okay!
I couldn't tell.
Oh, mixed?
Okay.
God, he should be playing Zangief the way you're gripping him up.
That's
probably burnt.
Aki, clean a burn out.
Yep, yep.
That's fine.
Whatever.
Wasted that.
Oh my goodness.
That's so clean.
Round two.
That's where the gobs.
Oh no.
Okay, my door's getting knocked.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Nice, good defense.
Hopping over.
He just gassed right at the end.
At the very end.
Kind of just ran into the eyes.
Good throw.
Yeah, let's stop this.
Yep.
Nice.
I love this.
Not attacking.
Yep, he's not attacking.
Let's go.
Oh, he won't attack Willy.
Oh, okay.
Nice escape.
Wait, wait, it's fine.
It's fine.
Yep, nice.
It's over.
My god.
Wait, are you bullying him?
Yeah.
Sorry.
He blocked that with his forehead.
Alright.
Round one.
Fight.
Nice.
Watch the dry meter for a little bit.
Holy shit.
All these combos.
She's so cool, actually.
Good defense.
This guy.
He's jumping.
Nice gun battle.
Let's go.
Yep.
That's my gun.
That's so good.
That's how you're actually supposed to play the game.
Yeah.
He's getting ready.
Yep.
Nice save jump.
And the block.
Poison frog punish.
He's dead.
Highlight reel.
That was it.
My bad.
Anyway.
Nice.
Well played.
Yo, that reset was fucking cheeky, dude.
Yeah.
That was awesome.
That was mean, almost.
Does that mean coaches have to play next?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, okay.
But even if this was Sunday, they'd have to play since it was 2-2 anyways.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm nervous because I like his content.
I love your content, bro.
Cause me.
I'm not.
That's it.
He doesn't like you anymore.
I'm sorry.
Not after you did that opening.
He's gonna download you now.
You gotta hit select to leave that slot.
Oh.
How do I do that?
Yeah, it's not intuitive at all.
They're waiting on you.
My bad.
This guy is my rank against a legend.
Legend 97?
There's numbers?
A little bit of confidence.
No, you got this.
Coach, you got this, bro.
You can have him.
I didn't even realize there were numbers.
Let's go, dad.
Uncle?
Uncle Brian?
What is it?
Theo Brian?
Theo.
Wait, I gotta spectate.
This game sucks.
There you go.
The parry.
Ooh, three hits.
Nice.
Oh, that slide.
It's happening so fast.
Nah, this character, Rashid, is a problem.
Yeah, I know.
I fought one and Brian was like, yeah, welcome to Rashid.
Yeah, he was never minus.
I can barely comprehend what's going on.
It's so fucking fast.
This game is so fast.
Aren't.
In the corner.
I miss fashioning.
Rashid is so bullshit, dude.
That is such bullshit.
Oh, my God.
You got Rashid.
What's
going on?
He's just spinning.
Oh, my God.
You got
that?
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Rashid's good and JB's cracked.
He's been cracked for years.
I gotta win the first round.
Once he gets to level two, that's when it's like...
Brawl pros left the room again.
Why are they doing that?
SK got left out, too.
Wait, I'll see you.
I got left out.
They're like, this team's over.
Let me see if I can just watch Brian.
Just the stream, yeah.
Yeah.
He's kicking everyone out.
The perfect carry.
God, this is...
This is so...
What do you even do?
My eyes are just cross-eyed just watching this.
There's too many...
It's just so fast.
Yeah.
There's people moving in, so my dog's hearing in.
He's like, who the fuck are these people outside?
The puppy.
God, here we go.
Time to play the mini-game here.
This is the greatest level two in the game.
Yep.
It has some, too, actually.
Oh my gosh.
Racist storm.
Oh my god.
Oh, that fucking level two, dude.
You gotta win the first round.
Good try, Brian.
Good try, man.
I forgot how round robin works.
Do we get points for each person that wins a round, or just the team winning the round?
I think a match.
So every player that wins a team has points.
Plus one?
Oh, okay.
So that's a plus one for every...
I don't remember.
It's been a while.
I think everyone who gets points counts, right?
We don't have to win the whole thing.
Yeah.
What matters is Sunday.
Well, I mean, the seeding is important, too.
I guess.
But, like, as long as we do well in round robin, too, right guys?
So the seeding gives you a buy?
Is that the point?
If you're in the top two teams, you get the buy.
I think it's not guaranteed, but it helps, I think, is what he said.
Oh, it definitely helps.
It does, so you don't have to play too many games.
Well, like, I don't know if top two is guaranteed.
I don't know.
It's something that Sajam said about it.
Not guaranteeing it, but it helps.
I don't know what he meant.
Or if I misunderstood.
He said we're doing something extra, too, on Sunday.
I don't know.
In the orientation, he mentioned something.
Oh, I was playing my ranked game.
I was not paying attention to the orientation.
I was hoping you guys were paying attention for me.
Was that all for that one?
Yeah, we're done with that team.
Now we're moving on to the next one.
Okay, guys, I took off the King mod.
I should be a little bit better now.
That's why that's exactly what it was.
Good stuff.
Dude, Espen does not play like a goal.
That rank was throwing me off.
He was getting coached by J1 yesterday, I think.
Yeah, Espen has that old school awareness.
He does some weird stuff, but his decision making is still pretty good.
Reminds me of Brazilian walk by Candice.
Kind of, yeah.
It's both kind of crunchy, but still good.
Yeah, it's like, how are you hitting me?
That type of gameplay.
But it works.
It just works.
So, who do we play next?
There was a bracket somewhere.
It's Dia.
Is it Dia?
Where are you playing?
Diaphone.
Yeah, Diaphone.
What did you say?
Dia.
Oh, Dia.
I thought you said Quesadilla for a second.
Diaphone?
Yeah, isn't Diaphone our next matchup?
Yeah.
I think, for me, I realized because in Tekken, I could get backseated, but Street Fighter, I get way too overwhelmed if I get backseated too hard.
Like I said, whatever style you want, if you just want some feedback, maybe be in between games.
Yeah, maybe in between matches.
This one, I have to think too much, and I get so overwhelmed.
Yeah, so whatever kind of feedback you want, just let us know.
Oh, you have to fight PDX.
Oh, the runback!
It's the runback.
It's gonna be a runback, dude.
Oh, man.
Alright, I'm ready.
You're fighting Sykkuno, Doki.
The thing is, I've matched up against him like twice in rank, but like, I don't know.
It's different when, because I'm playing, when I play off-stream, it's easier, but when you're streaming in a tournament, it's, my mind goes...
The nerves get kicking.
Yeah, yeah.
Because like, during off-stream rank, it was fine playing against Sykkuno, but then like, I don't know.
I'm not doing the things I should be doing.
Yeah.
Yeah, in tournament, you kind of have to just be able to just autopilot almost.
I'm kind of afraid of box-to-box a little bit, but I did beat him in ranked, but I don't know.
He's just wild.
He's solid.
I was pretty impressed with his gameplay.
They did some kind of Pax West thing, Justin Wong.
Yeah.
He cannot get, like, his anti, I can't jump at him.
Yeah, he can't jump.
He can't really random DI.
Are you just waiting?
Are your games done, or are you still going?
I'm gonna check if the mod's off.
Okay.
I installed the mod.
So I guess the columns are the stages, so we'll be in stage one coming up.
Oh, I see, I see.
I think that's what they're trying to do.
I think so.
That's way more before and like previously.
We didn't even know until later.
Stage one.
I guess Team Diathlon is still playing.
How did JB do at EVO?
He got top 64, maybe?
Oh, really?
You gotta understand with Street Fighter, you can't look at any one tournament.
JB also went super far at the Capcom Cup LCQ.
He beat the best player there twice.
But then, there's two more international players and too much talent to even look at one tournament.
Like Daigo ate shit at EVO.
A bunch of people eat shit at EVO.
Street Fighter, there's so many high-level players from the entire planet going to these tournaments.
It's a first-to-two game in a game that shouldn't be first-to-two.
So it's super volatile.
That's so crazy to me still.
But JB's pretty Capcom Cup and stuff.
Yeah, I don't understand why it's first-to-two.
This shit ends instantly.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, that game was so fast.
The coach game...
Yeah, when it's optimized...
I close my eyes and then I open and then the game's over.
Rashid can rush down like fucking crazy.
So what do you do against that character?
That character seems a little crazy.
Boy, don't ask me.
I don't fucking know.
That character's a problem.
I think he's the best in the game right now.
Yeah.
At actual high level against Rashid, you are in the vortex.
And then you just have to... if he gets level two, you just can't do anything.
That's the problem.
So he won the first round and then he got level two, then I couldn't play.
That's just how it goes.
You kind of have to win the first round and then lose the second round and force him to pop level two and then win the third.
Did you analyze the Evo Grands?
How Punk... what he did against the... I'm so curious of what you could do against that.
Well, Punk is...
Well, Cammy is different too.
Cammy has a lot more ways to approach but Punk is inhuman.
Like...
His footsie game is just... no one on the planet has level footsies.
And he gets right a lot.
He did a lot of wake up OD divekicks so you can avoid the throw loop pressure with jump forward into a divekick.
So if they go for a throw loop, you're in the air and then you punish them.
They were both doing that a bunch of each other.
He did win with a jump in also.
That was a funny jump in.
After all that, it just comes down to regular ass jump ins.
I do think that the Grand Finals don't they play a lot together?
They're like really good friends or something so they play a lot.
Who?
In the Grand Finals I think it was Angry Bird and Punk.
Punk and Big Bird.
Yeah, I mean they played a bunch.
I mean they're from UAE though.
They don't play online on the regular.
Oh yeah, that's right.
But they've definitely played a lot.
Normally Punk always beats Big Bird.
Like, the fact that he got it so close was kind of big for Big Bird.
Hmm.
Yeah, but the birds Angry Bird and Big Bird, they're both fucking cracked.
They're probably getting the...
Yeah, I'm watching the iPhone stream.
They're not in a match.
Oh, okay.
We're in stage one.
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay.
We're up.
I think they signed me Oh, I just got it.
I just got it.
Guys, chat remember if I lose every game, Jwon coached me.
Let's blame Justin.
Blame Justin.
That's why she had two coaches.
Definitely not me.
No, no, no, no.
If I win, Brian coached me.
If I lose, Jwon coached me.
Exactly.
Nobody mastering option selects Doki.
God, you're crap.
There we go.
Angry and Big Bird aren't the only birds that are cracked at this game.
Damn.
I like that instant P player one pick.
Hell yeah.
Instantly.
Frame one.
Dude, that execution was nuts.
I don't understand.
Even if it's 2D, why can't we...
Do you play on Baderon?
Yeah.
Why can't they mirror it?
It's very the same thing anyway.
I think she's leverless.
I'm leverless.
Leverless.
This is like the third time I've heard since this has started, like Tekken players complaining about mirroring in Street Fighter.
Tekken players love to complain, dude.
Just learn the other side.
No, I just love to complain in general.
Shaking fists at Cloud right now.
Learn player two.
I just like to complain overall.
But that shit matters in Tekken.
Like, that matters a lot actually.
I learned like a little bit of Paul on player one side and I got put to player two side one time and I didn't know anything.
Yeah.
That's when you go for the two grab.
Easy.
Literally everything went out the window.
The generic two grab.
Yeah.
Or I would do that grab on...
Is that the sides flop grab?
I would do that on accident and I'd be like, I just fucking threw the game.
It's over.
Can we quit?
He's trolling.
Nice.
Okay.
We're stage one.
I'm calling heads.
Heads.
Heads?
I call it now.
You should say, you should really mix them up and say like, hails.
Just to see what they would do.
He's just trying to sabotage you.
Because he's heard the rumors.
That I can't play rumors.
I was very loud and proud that I can't play rumors.
He's flipping.
I'm flipping.
Damn you got it.
Another one.
Let's go.
Wow.
Oh god this is the amor fucking love you.
Good luck SK.
Y'all got me right team.
I got you.
You're Sykkuno.
I have to play Super Show.
Cause he just.
Alright.
I think he knows too cause like, I've been grabbing him all day.
So he's mad.
Grab him.
Some more dude.
Nice.
Movement.
Oh.
My respect hitting.
God damn stream lighter.
Awe.
Didn't get the.
Sorry my dog.
That dog's hyping you up.
It's your hype man.
You're good.
People there's somebody moving.
Nice.
Grab out of the DI.
Let's go.
Nice.
Aw.
Oh get him.
Yes.
Yes sir.
Nice.
Doki please stop biking.
Stop biking.
He's hype about the geese.
He's hype yeah dude.
Your dog's a grappler man too.
Stop biking.
Oh my goodness.
Oh shit.
I think that hits me.
Please.
Get focused.
Continuing mission.
Oh shit.
I don't get serious.
No.
That's clean.
Let's go my loyal fans.
Please.
Get the first people moving.
Stop.
Nice.
One more.
Oh.
That was clutch.
This is crazy.
How did you have the instinct?
You might not know what you just did Doki.
I don't know.
I don't know what I did.
You were playing Tekken right there.
I don't know.
I don't know what I did.
Just unleash the demons Doki.
Get going.
Oh shit.
I don't know.
That's a Doki Zeme dude.
Hell yeah.
Oh my.
Oh she knows.
No he put me on the other side.
He actually knows.
Keep him there.
Nice.
Here we go.
Yeehaw.
The Doki Zeme.
The Doki Zeme dude.
Oh, here we go.
Let's go!
Bro, that freeze frame with the...
Dude, Sykkuno's kind of blessing us by playing Cammy.
I like this matchup.
Okay!
3-0'd!
I fucked it in three times!
Okay, I know I can beat Sykkuno at least.
Doki, every time you do level three, just shout, my loyal fans.
Even with my dog debuff.
I think he buffed you out.
I'm thinking the same.
That duck was crazy.
Alright, SK, you got this.
Oh, you're right, Justin.
I can't believe it.
I'm playing you right now.
Thank you, Brydie, for the win, though.
I'm gonna cheese her out in some way.
I feel like Jory's the best pick.
SK, do you want... Oh, okay.
Flip a coin.
Flip a coin?
Dude, I'm down.
I want P2, but...
You want P2, but...
I wanna flip a coin anyway.
Flip a coin.
He wants to do it for fun.
Okay, fair enough.
Yeah, just for fun.
Yo, you got it!
Okay, I pick P2.
Nice.
P2?
What a waste of resources.
Oh, yeah, dude, seriously.
You freak.
Who the fuck really thinks P2?
Okay,
I got my one win.
Now I can...
Now I don't have to try anymore.
I gotta run to the bathroom.
Before my match, I'll be right back.
That was my entire goal for today.
Just win one game.
That's mine, too.
My goal.
You guys got it.
Gotta do this.
Come on.
Time to play.
Round one.
Oh, no.
What?
She has those.
It says what?
She's got the DI reactions.
Oh.
There you go.
Really good throw.
Yup.
Let's go!
Oh, nice!
And the combo.
What's the team winning?
Let's go!
Oh!
No, no, no, no!
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Composure, composure.
You got this.
No!
Okay, the two grabs is plus.
Oh, it's almost.
I can win.
Nice.
Good punish.
Oh, the reaction.
Oh, good DP.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, fee entry.
Nice combo.
Oh.
You're in there, you're in there.
Yeah.
If you win this, it means your true rank is plat.
True.
Yeah, exactly.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh!
You're just as good as a plat player!
Let's go, let's go.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, I'm just gonna load this up.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Okay, but they're burnt out, too.
Nice.
You're still in this.
Oh!
Whoa!
What the fuck was that?
Oh, get him!
Nice.
Get him!
Oh, my.
No!
Yeah!
Holy shit!
What a combat!
Let's go!
You're cracked!
Oh, my God!
The comeback was insane!
Let's go!
Magic pixel is real.
Get it?
Yeah!
That was sick!
She's such a gamer, dude.
Nice.
Really good.
That's a nice hit.
Nice.
Full combo.
Oh, my God.
Silver play?
Who knows combos?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
That was good by her.
Oh.
Oh, that was crazy.
Oh, I'm the one burnt out.
Oh, you looked at the wrong bar?
Yeah.
That was kind of scrambly.
I get confused, too, all the time.
Sometimes.
Wait.
Is this the second round?
Or is it the third?
Yeah.
Okay.
I lost count.
It's 1-0, right?
Yeah.
1-0.
Okay.
The games are going by too fast.
Oh, you can't react in that move.
Yeah.
She'll always...
She's spamming that.
So, if you jump over her, she's gonna do that.
So, just do it.
You can jump over or also just wait.
Like, all she's doing is doing...
And what's the big reward?
Big reward is just to do it back.
Yeah.
You can probably grab more, too.
To be honest.
That, too.
Grab can work.
And also, if you just wait.
Like, I would just wait a little bit.
Okay.
Like, don't always take your turn back.
She's just gonna do DI right after.
Okay.
Just block a little and then do the DI.
When she does how's this, you can DI that, like, one, two, how's this, I think.
Right?
Do better next time.
Yeah.
But, I mean, in general, like, the game plan should be block her sequence and then wait for the DI.
Get her.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, get her.
Good block.
Good punish, too.
Oh.
Nice.
That was good.
Let's go.
Oh.
You're good.
Don't worry.
Nice.
That was fucking clean.
Let's go.
Win a ball.
Keep it up.
Okay.
I like that.
Ooh.
Nice.
She's tired.
Yeah.
She's jumping a lot.
Yep.
Ooh.
I kind of like that, though.
I don't know.
Yeah.
That's kind of sick.
Nice.
Yeah.
She's just going to DI.
So.
Oh.
That's okay.
Okay.
You also used your super.
Nice.
Oh, fuck.
Good try.
Oh.
Nice try.
Yeah.
You wanted to level three.
That was smart.
That matchup was very doable for you, SK.
Yeah.
You can definitely win this.
On Friday.
Oh, absolutely.
Yeah.
And you swapped mains, so then you had less time to learn, too.
Versus Amore.
True.
And my character's low tier, and like, hers is top one.
Jury's low tier.
I see so many.
There's no fucking way the amount of juries I see.
No, no.
She's bottom one.
Not absolutely.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I agree.
I see so many juries.
No, but that's not because she's good.
That's because people are degenerate.
Are freaks?
Yeah.
No, I get it.
Freaky, dude.
Yeah.
Juries never won a tournament, so...
True.
In tournaments?
Yeah.
Oh shit.
It's brawl pro time.
That's a lot of degenerates.
Jeez.
All right.
Here we go.
This is a match of all time right here.
Oh, the run back.
Fuck.
Okay.
Speed time.
Nice.
Ooh.
Mash and throw, huh?
Yeah.
Ooh.
Nice.
Here we go.
Oh, come on.
If I can...
If I beat a Cammy, you should be able to beat a Cammy.
Wait for it.
Hold on.
Oh.
Nice.
Are you alive?
Okay.
I was going to say, I don't think he's alive.
Dude.
Keeper's kind of a tank, but...
Not that tanky.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Oh, these combos are clean.
Yep.
Here we go.
Ooh.
Oh, my God.
Magna hands.
Down, down.
Jeez.
Oh, my God.
That's catching me.
That low.
Yeah.
That was gameplay.
Is that a kill?
Yeah.
You're alive.
Slow forward drive rush.
I'll watch out for that.
And she's burnt.
So, no meter.
You're in a good spot.
All right.
Here we go.
He knows about your move.
You do it too much.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Nice.
Brother.
Oh, that was sick, actually.
That was really good.
I can't believe that reached.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Nice.
Yeehaw.
Oh.
My little friend.
Oh, that was good.
This is your last ride.
Nice.
What the hell?
Oh, whoa.
Damn.
He's burnt, though.
It's all good.
Dead.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Dishman.
Nice.
Let's go.
My man kept his composure, and he's looking good today.
Look at that.
That's a handsome guy.
There's a mohawk right there.
Oh my god, people are still moving.
Is there hurt?
You're just evening it out for him?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, he's in the corner.
Time to play.
Oh, nice empty jump.
Okay, okay.
Oh, the knee!
The knee grab!
His signature move.
Nice!
My man was scared, dude.
Carry us in your backpack, bro.
Yes.
I'll sit comfortably here, dude.
Let's go get him!
Scramble.
Scramble the eggs.
Nice.
The knee throw.
That's so nasty.
It brought him to Masters.
I think he learned.
Oh, unless...
Okay, you're alive.
No!
Oh, nice!
That's a wrap!
Let's go!
You know he's upset, dude.
You know he's upset.
I thought...
I thought he might try to bait that, but...
It's 2-0.
He couldn't get one.
Damn.
Alright, time to get bodied.
Let's go.
You got this.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, who are you fighting?
I don't even know who you're fighting.
Box, box.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, just let...
Don't do too many random DI's or anything.
Oh, I don't DI like ever.
I believe!
But I do jump a lot.
If you do the close jumps, it should be fine.
It should be fine.
He does like cross cuts and stuff.
It's crazy.
Right, right.
That sounds insane.
Round 1.
Your MR number is higher, therefore you are better.
Yes.
I lost to an iron.
On the first match.
Warm up game.
That's true.
I had all the D-Bus going in.
So...
Nice.
Okay,
I think you played with your food a bit too much.
But...
That was a scam.
You can win.
Nice.
Good defense.
Oh, wow.
Oh, nice.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Oh, my gosh.
This is intense.
He dropped.
Yeah, he's good.
Oh, god.
Nice break.
No grab.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, that was good.
Yeah, modern players, they just wait for that.
Yeah, modern players are gonna do that instantly.
Yep.
Okay.
That's winnable.
I believe.
ADP, the first chance he got on wake up 2, I felt like.
Okay.
I just thought we were in the train session, because I was like...
Is this a timeout?
Nice.
Whoa!
Oh, that wasn't a try brush.
Nice challenge.
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah, he's low.
Oh, I wanted to grab it.
Oh, good job.
DI in the corner.
And DP.
Yeah, he loves that shit.
He can react to the drivers with the DP.
Nice.
Oh, that was a perfect parry.
Oh, nice.
Oh,
nice.
Damn.
This is such an intense matchup.
Yeah, the defense is pretty good.
Yeah, both sides are just defending really well.
Random DI.
You're alive.
Nice.
We have critical.
Oh, nice!
Oh!
That was a good try.
That was a bad drop.
That's my biggest problem, dude.
I drop a lot.
I don't know.
Would have level 3 worked there?
Yeah.
I could have actually killed without level 3.
I was going for the big...
Her stun combos are outrageously good.
Yeah.
They do a ton of damage and they set up for Oki or they kill.
You know he was good.
He was mashing, man.
Yeah.
That was a good try, though.
He won't get so lucky next time.
We haven't lost a game that I don't think we can win in...
What day is it?
In two days.
Friday, yeah.
When it was working, when it's obvious, I feel like it's good.
For Friday, it's easy to...
Because he was DP, wake up, and when you're in the corner...
So that's a lot of neutral jumps.
I think I know what to do with neutral jumps when he's neutral jumping bubble.
She gets some crazy conversions.
She's really good.
She started looking up a ton of stuff.
She got a lot of crazy stuff.
I got some answers.
I just can't jump at him.
Yeah, we'll go over all the matches, too.
Should be fun.
I'm super down.
Wait, what are the points for round one versus round two?
I know round two is five, but what's round one?
I think it's less points.
It's like one or two points.
It's three?
Yeah.
Let's go, coach.
Coach, let's do this.
Oh, he's also an Aki.
Yeah, he plays...
He's one of the better Akis out there.
Do you watch his guides?
No, I watch this guy from the UK called Broski.
That's why my name is Hispanic Broski.
Because he's considered to be one of the best Akis in the world.
I see.
Wow!
He had no rank 97 bullshit.
He had no legend rank.
Legend rank is pretty much the apex predator of Street Fighter.
It's like the top 500.
Fucking JB, man.
Nephew is up there, too, actually.
He's like...
Yeah, isn't Nephew insane, too?
Yeah, he's one of the best juries in the world.
Right behind me, of course.
Right behind SK.
Maybe you can ask Nephew to coach you.
Just, like, stroke his ego and be like, Hey, I heard you're really, really good at Jury.
I won't beat your player, don't worry.
Yeah, yeah.
But then if it's really fucked up, he coaches you the wrong thing.
Just so...
No, just be a double agent.
Like, yeah, don't worry.
I'm not gonna do anything crazy.
Like, I just love Street Fighter so much that I wanna keep playing Jury afterwards.
Nephew, you're my biggest...
I'm your biggest fan, Nephew.
Can you please coach me?
I watched all your streams and YouTube videos.
I'm gonna subscribe to your YouTube.
I watch all your content.
I'm a tier 3 subscriber on Twitch, please.
Can you teach me how to play?
Sorry, are we distracting you?
Brian's like, these children.
Nice.
Yes!
You don't make fun!
Okay, not nice.
Okay, I'm gonna stop distracting you.
Three bars versus zero bars.
I'll do the same to Diaphone.
I'll be like, Diaphone, I've been your subscriber since...
I don't know when, dude.
I'm a tier 3 subscriber.
I'm number one on your stream, lads.
I'm a Patreon sub.
This match is kind of fire, though.
Yeah, this match is nice.
Oh, the overhead.
Big combo here.
Nice!
Let's go!
Level 2 shenanigans?
I saw that Evo!
Yeah, let's go!
Coach, you got those!
Isn't that hard to do?
Oh, she jumped out.
Okay.
Wait, it doesn't do that much damage.
It's like more corner carry than anything else.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say.
It looked cool, though.
Oh, it's super flashy, dude.
Another one!
Okay, here we go.
Almost there.
Just block it.
Oh, that was a good jump in, dude.
Oh, he doesn't have... oh, that's death.
Level 2, yeah.
Oh, that was a good jump.
That was a good jump.
Yeah.
That combo was sick.
Popcorn?
What do we need?
No, these guys are playing like...
Playing, playing.
Competitive Street Fighter is crazy, dude.
Oh, here we go.
Wow!
Nice.
Nice mash.
Thanks.
Woo!
I can actually understand this game compared to the last one.
The Rashid...
When Rashid's on screen...
It's like a live Twister.
Oh!
That was good on their part.
Yeah.
I think I should have learned Rashid.
Nice.
Stand still.
Stand still!
I saw that clip.
It was mad funny.
No!
Oh my god!
Keep going!
Oh, Empty Jump Low!
Let's go!
Yeah, I might have been able to kill without the Level 3, but...
It's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's content.
I love that jump into the lane.
That was great.
Empty Jump Lows are like...
Chef's kiss.
As money.
I'm deep.
I don't have the best one, but...
Nah, dude.
You have the best one.
Which is grab them.
Empty Jump Grab.
True.
Eat it!
Let's go!
Oh no!
It's fine.
You don't need it.
It's that negative.
Uh-uh-uh.
Oh my god.
We're good.
Nice backdash.
Let's go, coach!
Yes!
That was good.
Oh, don't be mashing on me, Amigo!
Nice!
Oh my god.
Let's go, dude.
That's crazy.
I gotta tell you, that super is one of the coolest supers ever.
The Muhammad Ali, dude.
For this next one, you're gonna wanna do more damage than he does to you.
Noted.
Oh, nice parry!
Oh my god.
He's so good.
Punish counter.
Let's go.
Oh!
Oh, Lupa's ass.
Do it again!
No, no, no.
You should have...
He'd be like, that's something a silver would do.
Holy shit!
Okay, that shit's crazy.
I thought that was a perfect first second.
Yeah, Ko, maybe you shouldn't ask him for coaching.
Maybe...
I mean...
Do what you just did to him.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Coach is cracked right now.
Empty jump low!
Oh, fuck it.
We ball.
Yo.
What happened to the boss?
Oh, no shot.
Let's go!
Oh!
You're mine!
Oh my god.
We're good, we're good.
Guys, I'm always...
Nice break, nice defense!
Guys...
Let's go, let's go coach.
What does neutral mean?
Oh god.
Did Justin not go over this in the...
I was afraid to ask for a very long time, but people kept saying this to me.
So you know how they're not doing anything right now?
Yeah.
And the first thing that they do to open the other person up is called the neutral.
So right now they're playing neutral.
They're trying to feel each other out.
Nice!
Nice neutral, man!
So like, what does it mean when people say good neutral?
What Brian just did.
Weren't you watching?
That's what Brian just did.
I waited this long to ask because...
Nice work.
Coach, Mrs. Bird needs help.
That was good.
What does neutral mean?
Listen, Doki, for you, don't worry about it.
Oh, okay.
Like I said before, you're asking for some coaching and all that in the beginning, and I really feel like what's just not poising your mind.
But people were like, wow, Doki can do some good neutral.
I'm like, what does that mean?
Just say thank you, and keep doing you.
That's what I think.
Okay.
When you don't know what you're doing, you're doing it right.
Hey guys, I have a two win streak.
Yay.
Let's go.
Sweet.
So we won that match.
Technically speaking.
Overall, right?
3-2.
Who are we fighting next?
Good stuff, team.
We're 1-1.
There's good data on all these matches.
I really feel like most of these matches, like we'll go through them, there's just tiny things for everybody we can all just tweak.
I don't think any of these matches are a lost cause at all.
I think they're all super close.
We're up against Nephew next.
Nephew.
Who's on his team?
Go to the news section, and you'll see it.
It's Skara, Red, Nephew, Huntress.
Wait, who's their fourth?
Wait, who's their...
Lily.
Yeah, I face Lily and playing Lily.
Easy.
Ross is Master's DJ.
So that'll be fun.
You're playing Ross?
Yeah, he's a Master's DJ.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, gotcha, gotcha.
He's a Master's DJ?
We got a lot of people in second tier.
Jump, jump, medium kick, and random DI.
That's gonna be your way to get in.
Okay.
I'm gonna forget the headbutt, Justin.
I'm gonna forget it.
I'm gonna go take a quick bathroom break, guys.
Good stuff.
Are they done with their matches, or are they still going?
Are you peeing?
Don't pee.
Hold that shit in.
Hold it?
Yeah, it works.
Is this why I haven't been winning every tournament?
I've been going to the bathroom and pissing myself?
You gotta hold it in.
Today's the day.
And then you go.
Do not do that, Brian.
I'm telling you.
Alright?
It works.
It actually works.
It makes you concentrate more.
Just watch.
Because I know in competitive in general, it actually does work.
Because you focus more.
Yeah, yeah.
It's an actual, real thing.
I don't do it, but it's a real thing.
It's real.
Bathroom over-competitiveness for me.
Nephew is playing right now.
I'm actually gonna watch that.
How do I watch that?
His stream?
I assume.
Oh yeah.
Oh dude, if you're in his stream, link it in the chat.
It's like Nephew dork or something.
Nephew dork.
Oh, they just finished.
Oh, they just finished?
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
That was a stream.
13k viewers on Street Fighter 6, that's pretty good.
Oh, Lily's back on Twitch.
Oh, really?
I thought she was on YouTube.
I didn't realize she was back on Twitch.
Justin, how do I kill Lily again?
I forgot.
She's live right now.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh, wait.
Manon is all about that command grab, right?
Manon?
Yeah.
Careful with her burnout pressure.
Getting burnout by Manon is scary.
And he loves his standing medium pressure.
Okay, I'm gonna jump permanently.
Until he anti-ears me.
Okay.
Is there a way to deal with Manon burnout pressure?
Like, do you get hit by it or something, maybe?
Oh, did he go to the bathroom?
Yeah, he did.
He hasn't come back yet.
Damn.
Well, this is GG's, guys.
He went to go piss.
Dude, that Ed match was really cool.
Ed is really fun in this game.
In Street Fighter 5, he was...
I didn't...
No one liked Ed.
But here, he's cool.
Yeah, it's cool watching him.
Oh, they tagged us.
Are we done?
They haven't invited us yet, though.
Stage 1.
Let's see.
Hits.
Yeah, no, do the coin flip.
It's traditional at this point.
Okay, just hurry up into player 1, and then if they say something, then be like, flip a coin.
Yeah, but what if she gets there before me?
I'm not that fast.
JK, I am.
You are.
Yeah, there you go.
None of that loser mentality.
JK.
I'm in.
I'm fucking in.
I wonder how other people are doing this.
Is there a score?
Oh, there's match report.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm looking at the match report right now.
Uh...
This is so confusing.
So many different people are in here.
Wait, Fii won against Red.
Fii 2-2-1 Red RiotRoss.
Oh, he did?
Yeah.
Wow.
Huntress won against BoxBox, though.
Huntress is really good.
Yeah.
But, Coeficient got it.
She's pretty good, though.
I don't know why.
She's really good.
But, Coeficient is better.
Dia lost to Nephew.
Uh... Not really that surprised.
To me.
Hey, whoa.
I mean, Nephew, though.
It is.
Like, we can all agree Nephew is really good at this game.
Yup.
Fucking smack.
Infer... Infer won against Huntress.
Infer won against Huntress.
Oh, wow.
He's... Damn, dude.
Coeficient, you got it.
Infernasu?
Yeah, no.
Akuma's a...
Akuma's a bitch, dude.
Yeah, Akuma's a problem.
Akuma's a hoe, dude.
You lost your...
Did I lose my coin flip?
You lost?
I lost my coin flip?
No, I didn't.
Watch this.
What are you gonna do?
I need to see this.
Is he edited next to the message?
Question mark.
Got him.
Instant DQ.
I almost have to agree with SolidBones.
What?
He doesn't have proof?
He doesn't have proof that he chose heads?
Show me the mod logs.
You won't.
All I'm saying is that...
Is that...
I chose tails.
Guys, I have vouchers, right?
Does anyone want to vouch me that I chose heads?
Or tails?
Sorry, I lagged there.
I got you.
Voucher, I was...
There you go.
Yeah, I chose tails.
SK voucher.
I was the coin.
Voucher, I was the coin.
Shit, it was tails, bro.
I saw that shit.
Those who are wondering what I wrote in the discord, give me a sec.
Guys, this is proof that I chose tails, guys.
This is proof.
Right here.
See?
I told you.
Tails.
Vouch.
It's tails.
It says tails right there.
It literally says it right there.
Bro, just screenshot it and post it again.
And just add our question mark.
I know when they start, I'm on the Sajam stream.
Stop corrupting the...
I'm just telling the truth.
Stop corrupting people.
Are they putting us on stream again?
Is that what's going on?
Again?
No clue.
I don't know.
No, we're waiting for people.
Some people are not there yet.
I feel like stage 2 is the stream.
That's what...
Why the fuck is V here?
Why is so many people here?
This is more...
Why is V here?
Yo, thanks, space.
Guys, please.
I don't know how to play P2.
Oh, they're trying to make sure the rounds start at the same time.
I see.
That's why.
That makes sense, actually.
I'm gonna go get some water.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Water break.
I'm fighting Lily as Lily.
You ready?
No, but like...
There's not enough Lilies in rank.
All she does is she's gonna try to fly at you randomly.
Yeah, like that shit throws me off so much.
Cause like my lariat still timing is not great.
Yeah, you can't really lariat that.
She tries to build up her stores by spinning and then she flies at you.
Yeah, I just have to block, which everyone knows that I'm bad at.
If it has a bunch of wind effects, that's the only one you gotta block.
The other ones where she flies at you without a bunch of special effects, get to mess.
But that's about it.
Other than that, your regular game plan should work.
Alright.
Should be nothing to worry about.
She is aware that I'll grab a lot.
So I'll never grab.
I'll fuck with her.
No, you have to.
I have to grab.
You tried triangle at good times.
Okay, they're telling you to get off player one.
What?
That's not fair.
How did I lose?
I mean, it is fair.
I don't understand.
I clearly picked tails.
Okay, but if she wins this one, I should be on...
You can just jump over her.
I could be on the other side.
You can just walk up and do a jump.
And you're probably gonna sideswap like 15 times during this game.
I know, don't worry about it.
We'll be okay.
Blame Justin Wong.
You hear that, Justin?
Justin's a double agent.
He also coached Lily.
He coached everyone I'm fucking fighting, dude.
That shit is rough.
Except me.
I guess I didn't ask him.
Yeah, you didn't ask him.
I didn't want to bother the guy, man.
Like, he's busy.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Awesome time.
Oh, unlucky.
Oh, yeah.
I hate that so much.
Don't worry.
She's just a silver one.
Yeah, I lost to an iron.
That's not a thing anymore.
Oh...
Dude, that is not Lily on the sticks.
Can we get a face cam, please?
Do we need the hand cam?
Oh, my God.
It's so fast.
It's like nobody runs Lily, so I'm so confused.
Oh, my God.
We just have to block that.
What the heck, Lily?
Oh, I pressed triangle.
Yeah, but she's going to move first.
If she does the fancy one, that's the problem.
You got to get out of the way after.
It looks the same.
That's the thing.
They all look the same to me.
We'll have to train some Lily.
So, just this game, walk up to her first and DI first.
Okay.
So, she's doing a bunch of big moves from far away then flying at you.
Just walk up and DI first.
Yeah.
Like, get in there first.
Yeah, get in there now.
Nice.
So, you can keep rushing her down until she gets her...
Okay.
Oh, my God.
She's blind.
There you go.
Just keep rushing her down.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh.
That's fine.
Okay.
Now, you got to block if she...
Yeah.
She's going to do the thing.
You're good.
Now, you can rush her down again.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, damn.
I come back and see...
If you rush her down at the beginning of the round, she's weaker.
Okay.
Going aggressive early is good.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
All right.
You hit the block here.
That's fine.
Now, try to rush her down again.
Oh.
Yep.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah.
And you can rush her down really hard now.
Yep.
Wow.
No.
That's fine.
You're alive.
You're a tank.
Did I hit that?
Yep.
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't know I hit that.
Does that kill?
I was critical, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
She's beyond dead.
Beautiful.
You gave her back pain.
That's how dead she is.
Okay.
I should be allowed to be player one after that.
I should...
You're kicking ass off player two.
Just rush her down.
Forget the damn sides.
I will never forget.
Get in there.
Uh oh.
Yes.
Nice.
Oh.
Unlucky.
I should have done the run through it.
Okay.
She's gonna fly at you any second.
Just try to block it.
And then jump after you're blocking it.
Oh.
I jumped though.
Good jump.
That was great.
Yeah.
Block.
Oh.
What?
That was bullshit.
That sucked.
Nice.
Get her.
She's burnt out.
Oh.
No shot.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Do I get this?
I do.
Yes.
Let's go.
I love how the rush her down is Siberian Express.
I mean he does rush her down with that.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh.
Get in there.
She got it.
No.
She grabs me.
Yeah.
You gotta jump to avoid the grabs after.
Okay.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
That's good too.
Did I get that?
No.
She got that over.
It's okay.
Composure.
Get that.
Wait.
You got it.
Yes.
Okay.
You got it.
Trust you.
One more.
She's gonna wake up soon.
She might wake up.
Okay.
It's okay.
Burned out.
Oh.
She grabbed me.
Yeah.
That's alright.
No worries.
Just rush her down again.
It's working.
Oh.
She knows now.
Did I hit that?
Oh.
No.
She...
Oh.
You gotta jump.
Sorry.
I should have told you.
That's a command grab.
I think she was too close, right?
Nah.
It's fine.
Okay.
You can rush her down.
What?
Oh.
Nice.
You can win this easy.
Yeah.
She has nothing to defend herself.
Nice.
No.
It's okay.
I don't think...
No.
She ducked.
That was close though.
Very close though.
Yeah.
You got the general flow of it.
You just didn't know about that wake up super.
We'll practice that.
That move, you can't block.
It's like geese.
You have to hold up.
Yeah.
That was so good.
That was literally the fourth Lily I've ever fought.
She's not popular at all.
I think the third or fourth Lily I've ever fought.
Same with the slow though.
You rush her down early and she's a lot weaker.
That's basically how it goes.
Yeah.
Scar is flat wide.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, you like clean too.
Nice.
Let's go, SK.
She looks like Lily.
From Temkin.
Oh, he had level one.
I forgot.
I did forget Justin.
Justin's trying to get you to do some fancy stuff.
We can practice that more, but that's kind of hard.
Manon looks like an ostrich in that first screen.
That's the most accurate depiction of Manon.
I think I've heard of.
He hair grabs.
It's so annoying.
Yeah, she's a command grab character.
So she might force you to jump or match.
I tried to jump both times there, but she did the hit thing instead.
Yeah, you can also just try mashing your OD reversal.
It's the uppercut.
Okay.
Or electric.
That's the mix up with this character.
Boom, boom.
Oh, nice.
Wow.
I thought that was my right.
Scar is gaming like that.
That's great.
I'm sorry.
It's flat.
That's gonna hurt.
Oh, that's gonna hurt a lot.
Oh, nice.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, these supers, both Manon and Lily, the big level threes, they're grabs.
You can just jump after they do it.
So they'll just whiff and you can kill them.
So he does that again with the level three and you're not just always hold up.
So we'll see if he does it again.
It'll just come into play at the end of the game.
Nice.
Nice, SK.
Oops.
It's not like a mom.
I'm in the event right now.
What was that?
Was that your mom?
Was that Brawl Mom interrupting this one?
Yeah, was that Brawl Mom, dude?
I think she wanted to do something.
It's supposed to be oil.
You're gonna take all the trash, BP, dude.
Sorry mom, I'm gaming.
I can't just leave.
You can't pause the video game.
Sorry for yelling, guys.
Aw, it's okay.
That was a good round.
I only muted my stream.
You forgot to mute!
There's too many controls.
There's apparently an Amazon package for me out there.
Nice.
Nice defense.
And they're burnt out.
Oh, what?
Nice jump.
Nice.
Yeah, that two-hit move is punishable.
I'm scared.
Get away from me.
Don't grab.
Nice fireballs.
No!
That was close.
Good try.
Good try, good try.
Were you trying to do the wake up electric?
I am.
I should have, but I was trying to jump.
Yeah, next time we can try that more.
He's doing hit or grab every time.
I guess to jump every time.
But I was wrong most of the time.
Yeah.
That's where the wake up reversal comes in handy.
You said DI.
He's susceptible to DI and what?
A medium kick?
Jump, medium kick.
If he's walking backwards.
If he doesn't have downcharge, he can't really anti-air you that good.
So you can walk up, jump, MK.
And if he's walking away, you can try random DI.
But it's all kind of a guess.
But don't be scared to DI.
Oh shit, Nephew's 84th rank.
That's higher than 97.
Yeah, Nephew's kind of cracked.
I'm telling you SK, just go in there.
I'm a big tier 3 sub.
Biggest fan.
I'm your number one donator.
You see that person that donated that much money?
That was me on my alt account.
I was watching his guide on YouTube.
But the problem is he's too good.
I can't replicate anything he does.
That went by so fast.
I literally just caught the end of that.
Nice.
You had enough.
I thought that had armor.
Let's go.
If anything, Broppo will always get us that one point.
I'm burnt out.
It's okay, you don't need it.
Yes!
Nice!
They messed up.
Everyone's scared in the face of the thief.
Yeah.
Nice!
Where are you going?
Level 3!
Nice!
That's yours!
My loyal fans!
Should be dead, right?
Yes, sir!
Random DI's.
Really good against DJ.
I'll keep that in mind.
I think I have to face DJ, too.
In this match?
Not in this one.
In the next one, I think.
Or the last one.
I think all Sham Noel plays DJ.
Wait, who hits first?
Oh, you!
Nice!
Sometimes you just can't tell.
Yeah, I can't tell who hits first.
Oh, you grabbed him.
That would be cool.
You're doing real good here.
He's scared, dude.
He's scared.
You'd be worse if you were on modern brawl, bro.
Not wrong.
Guaranteed DI.
Yes!
Nice!
I thought you were silent for a second.
That's sick!
That's his favorite whack-ass combo.
But there...
Brian was mad?
No, it was good.
Yo!
Oh my god.
Yo, that chop was so close to his face.
You can smell his fingers.
Nice!
My man is scared, dude.
Yeah.
Oh!
Fair enough.
He had to.
Yeah, he did.
Oh my god, look at all the music.
But you're in player one side now.
Brother.
Empty jump.
You got the good side.
The front comes in.
I just survived.
Okay, he might try to DI you.
So maybe you can wake up Super, potentially.
Just think about it.
Oh!
Oh, does it hit?
That was so close!
I respect it.
That was pretty good.
Maybe you're not meant for P1.
There we go.
Maybe you're a P2 gamer.
Oh, that was good.
Where you going, Amigo?
Oh, nice!
Burnout?
Yes!
Nice!
The stop!
What the fuck!
I knew he was gonna jump because of the burnout.
That's how you normally play, Keith.
Not what it looks like I'm doing.
Oh!
An actual anti-air.
I'm amazed.
Let's go.
Alright, let's see this.
Alright.
I'm actually there to spectate.
So who do you have here?
Uh, Huntress.
Oh, coin flip?
Oh, dude.
Tails.
Coin flip time.
Who's Huntress playing?
Uh, Chun.
Okay.
She's really good.
She probably has the highest MR out of anybody.
Damn.
It's like 1700, I think.
You know what?
I think for this matchup, I'm gonna have to, uh, rock another color here.
I'm gonna get some plot open back.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna rock...
uh, Laki.
There we go.
L.A.
Aki, dude.
Aki from L.A.
Damn, I lost the coin flip.
I, I...
That's what's up, man.
Okay.
Yeah, this is late Kurzaki.
Let's do this.
Why doesn't anyone like Player 2?
I love Player 2.
I don't mind Player 2 at all.
I just wanted to do it for mind games.
To be honest.
Player 1?
Yeah, that's fair too.
I should just take everyone's Player 1, actually.
Yeah, just for fun.
Do the...
Do the coin flip, dude.
Alright, let's lock in here.
What's the record?
Is it, uh...
What is it?
They have 2, we have 1, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I think so.
It is possible she doesn't know the matchup.
You know what I mean?
Oh my god, Popov.
I think Coefficient's just better.
I think so too, actually.
Woo!
Forgot about that.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Nice challenge.
That's confirmed.
I saw the vision.
Nice.
Beautiful!
Is she dead?
Level 2?
Yeah, I knew it.
Oh, I think I can...
Oh, you know what?
I think I could've slid after that.
Yeah.
Maybe just try it, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good round, though.
That's close.
Very close.
Round 2.
Fight!
She adapted really fast, too.
Them boys playing chess.
Beautiful.
Ooh!
Empty jump low!
Oh!
Let's go.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god, what a combo.
Set up.
One more.
Nice!
That was sick.
Let's get them shook.
Let's go.
They're first.
Nice.
Let's get that level 3.
Oh, I wanted... I was cheeky.
Cheeky.
Oh, they're burnt, though?
You're good.
Yeah, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Are you?
Is that critical?
Yeah, I think so.
Unless...
Oh, that's close.
That's close on both ends.
I have a question.
Is it hard to stun them on Aki if they're burnt when they're doing the strings like that?
No, but they can just super.
It's always a guess, right?
Yeah.
Aki's good at that, just like everybody else.
Okay, okay, got it.
It's a risk.
We only lost two of her supers.
Yeah.
Both browns.
Oh my god.
Nice tech.
Ooh!
That's an overhead, right?
Yeah.
What the hell?
Ah, there's some flubs there.
Don't worry about it.
Ooh.
That's nice.
Oh.
Nice!
Okay.
Nice.
Nice pressure.
Oh!
That was crazy from the Cheninni.
Yeah, like a movie.
Yeah, the blocking for that.
Good defense.
Bravo, no.
You're jinxed it.
I panicked.
I panicked so hard, dude.
They were choking, too.
I do.
Yeah.
That was bad.
God dang it.
I feel like I was doing good there.
It's just I don't know how to fight Cheninni.
We'll know by tomorrow.
Yeah.
Alright.
Time to watch the...
Time to watch this.
I believe.
Let's go.
Should we fun?
Yes.
Yeah, you said Juri's low tier, right?
Yeah, she's never won a big tournament ever.
Yeah.
Right?
For sure.
Yeah, and then there's like 500 EDs in top 8.
Right.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah.
500 EDs in top 8.
There was like 3 of them, bro.
Where was the Juri in that?
Yeah, where was the Juri in that?
Exactly.
Come on, coach.
You're literally meta.
What?
It's true.
You're distracting him.
I'm sorry.
I got him into a throw loop.
I'll take that.
Get him.
Dude, that's my bad.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, this is when Juri becomes top tier.
Hold on.
I thought you guys said she's off meta.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, nice.
Oh, coach is so good too.
That walk under?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, empty.
Oh, nice.
Dude.
It's time to be fancy with it.
Fuck it.
We ball, dude.
Oh.
That's good.
Oh, please block that.
Oh, no.
Good.
Nice mash.
Nice.
If he had level 2, that would have been dead.
Oh, the spacing.
Alright, alright, alright.
This is neutral, Doki.
Just letting you know.
Wait, which part?
This.
This entire thing?
That.
That was neutral.
That's neutral.
That's okay.
All he does is play Street Fighter.
He quit his job for this.
Brian, you know what to do.
You know what to do then.
You want that 50k.
You gotta be hungry, coach.
Come on.
Pretend like you have to pay rent tomorrow.
Ooh.
See, Doki, that was neutral.
This is rushdown.
I hate this fucking character.
Oh, the back dash.
Oh, here we go.
Oh.
Okay.
Here we go.
Ah, the burnout.
Oh my god, you're sick, coach.
Oh my god.
Is this good?
Let's go.
Ah, just barely.
Oh, that was close.
You were so good with it too.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
He's gonna do that thing.
Ugh, the mind games.
Yeah.
It's a lot of damage, dude.
I might be dead.
Yeah.
Oh, you might be actually dead.
SK, you know what to do.
You got...
Yeah, I think you're dead.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll just pull that out.
Yeah.
I got looped.
I got punished.
You know what you gotta do.
See, Doki, that was neutral.
Wait, which part?
The entire thing.
The entire game was neutral?
The entire game.
That's the part where they're not close to each other and they're looking for opportunities.
This is the team we have to lab.
Okay.
First practice.
Braving.
Good try, man.
And we can start by having SK go to Nephew and say, I'm your biggest fan.
Alright, I'm gonna add Nephew right now.
Nephew, please coach.
Add Nephew.
Can you coach...
Can you coach SK for us?
She's your biggest fan.
And was screaming for you instead of for our coach.
They don't know.
They don't check VODs.
That's good.
Alright, so who do we play next?
I think it's Team Shine.
What did he say to the reply?
I posted it in general.
Justin was like, I'll retweet it.
It was in our general chat.
Wait, you will.
That's not against Menon.
That's fine.
Just take all the info.
Do we know who's on Team Shine?
Let's go to the news.
Oh, SK!
You're in!
You're the best!
You're literally in!
So that's Kana, Yanagi...
Oh, V-Bright Shield and Umi and Infernasu.
Yeah.
Cool.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Now SK will be the next Nephew.
We're probably waiting here for a while.
Oh, really?
Yeah, S-fan and Fumi haven't even finished fighting.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck?
We started the same time, didn't we?
Are they on the Sage stream?
I don't know, actually.
Ormoy won his match.
Yeah, but you won against V2.
Yeah, dude.
No worries.
And you're fucking around with V2.
Jamie against Zangief is... I don't like it.
Yeah, no.
Jamie's kind of a bitch.
He's kind of a hoe.
I feel like I have to let him drink for free on Zangief.
I don't even know how you approach that match.
Yeah, you kind of have to approach him the whole time to prevent him from doing that.
What is that palm?
Can I light SPD it on block?
The OD version is...
I think they're all negative four now.
So, no, you can't do that as a guaranteed punish.
Oh, wow.
I mean, it's a mix-up, though.
You can try it, but it's not guaranteed.
Hmm.
Okay.
So, are they doing palm on you?
Like, randomly?
I don't remember how to fight against Bison.
Um, I don't know.
I guess we'll find out what happens.
How do I fight against Bison again?
Can she...
Like, light SPD is a scissor kick or anything?
Or no?
Yeah, but it has to be spaced.
If they space it, then you can't.
Damn.
But if they don't space it, then you can.
But it's like, that takes so much awareness.
So fast.
But, I mean, this is Rookie Raid, you know.
Oh my god, apparently I tilted Sykkuno.
He messaged me.
He was like, your Zangief traumatized and tilted me so high.
Because, like, we bumped into each other like two times in ranked.
So, like, in the end, it was like a 3-0.
Like...
Based Doki, dude.
Traumatizing Sykkuno.
I just fight so many Camis!
Like, literally every two games, it's a fucking Camis.
I'm so done.
Cami's really popular.
I run into a lot of Camis too.
She's everywhere.
I blame Punk.
It's not just Punk's fault.
That character is a problem.
It's because of outfit too.
It doesn't help that she has a nice booty either.
Yes.
Can I get an amen?
Every time Doki grabbed Cami, her butt was in full view.
Yeah, dude!
That would say the same thing, dude!
I'm like, thank you, Doki.
Keep grabbing, Doki.
Don't stop.
Maybe that's why he let me win.
Because it's just Koomer bait.
Well, you should tell Sykkuno that.
It's like, I know what you're doing.
It's fine.
You're throwing on purpose.
Hahaha!
Where are they at?
Where?
Oh.
So they're playing Now and Shine stream.
Okay.
Wait, can I play ranking?
You might have time for like one.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
One or two.
Yeah, they gotta do Infernasu and then they gotta do...
I think that's the last one for the coaches.
Alright, I'm gonna play ranking.
Mikko, have you...
Oh, he went AFK.
I need to warm up.
I'm ready.
I'll be right back.
Do you know who, uh...
Who are you playing?
SK?
Not Fumi.
Bright Shield?
Ed.
She's playing as an Ed.
Ed?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm playing against a Bison.
My random matchup is against a Bison.
What are the odds?
Is that the matchup you're gonna play right now?
Yeah!
What are the odds?
Oh, he knows.
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Where's your internet?
I don't remember the combo.
It's been a while since I fought a Bison.
That's the worst part.
I don't remember their moves sometimes.
Guys, internet is dog shit.
Oh, he's WiFi.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, please.
They're fucking with me right now.
WiFi.
Oh, shit.
Weed God beating your ass right now.
Bro, he's always...
That's the worst WiFi I've ever seen.
Look at this!
His router is stoned.
Don't worry about it.
Are you playing a match with WiFi?
Yeah.
I've never had...
The Weed God is in there.
The Weed God.
The Weed God is fucking me up.
Nope.
What the fuck is this?
Oh my god.
I don't have an answer on if Brian is single.
Oh.
No.
He has an answer for you again.
What?
He reacted to this.
Oh, damn.
I ran into BoxBox on the right.
Nice.
What do I do here?
The run back.
Give me the run back.
Jesus Christ.
If I win this, I'll be so surprised.
This fucking...
...
I can barely process anything right now.
I'm watching it in like five frames per second.
...
This is why we don't accept Wi-Fi matches.
I've never had such bad connections before.
Even against people in Asia!
This guy is in America!
I would probably trust him.
He's in America.
How was I supposed to know?
Don't worry.
His PS4 is on the router.
Oh my god.
I can't even watch this without lagging.
Your great training, but your Wi-Fi sucks.
I can't deal with it.
Do I have enough time to do another game or no?
No idea.
They were... they're still doing the second to last match.
Oh, okay.
I got into games.
I got into a game anyway.
Yeah, yeah.
You're good.
I just beat BoxBox again on ranked.
This is where it matters, actually.
This is actually where it matters.
I don't give a... I'm one and done.
Slam points.
I'm sorry.
I have to go play.
Yeah, rank points does not matter.
I won and done them.
I'm so sorry.
I gotta... I gotta go play...
Are we ready now?
No.
Oh, I thought we were...
Wait, what?
No, I'm saying...
Infernosu is playing Cosmonaut and they are going...
Oh, so they're not ready.
Okay.
Oh, I thought they were ready.
I'm so sorry, BoxBox.
I gotta send them out.
Just be like, I thought we were ready.
You're in tournament.
Listen, you can one and done in tournament.
That's fair game.
Tournament day.
Wait, who am I fighting on Shine's team?
Boomy?
That's the person below Infernosu?
That's the Ed player.
Okay.
I think so.
I think there's two Eds.
No.
Goodbye.
I think Ana and Koyanagi are viking in two Eds, then Infernosu and Akuma.
God and Shine.
I have to learn to block again.
I already forgot.
I promise I don't one and done like that BoxBox.
I promise.
Just don't hate me.
It's tournament day.
It's necessary.
Yeah, I was free to use the whole honorable box.
Let's go coach!
That's what I needed to hear!
That shit goes out the window.
Save it for tournament.
That's why I'm here.
Okay.
I'm done.
I'm down.
Tournament day one is done.
It's acceptable.
Yeah.
I agree.
So they're going at it for Nasu.
I mean, that's a showdown.
They didn't drag us.
Cosmonaut won.
Oh, he did?
Yeah.
They were struggling a little bit.
But they were going the distance.
Whose stream are you watching now?
I'm just watching Shine's stream.
Oh no!
Flash.
I think I just got the invite.
Oh, okay.
Good timing.
Alright.
So they're getting the lobby ready.
But they still gotta play.
Oh, wait.
So they're still playing?
I thought it was over.
I don't think Shine's played JB yet.
Is that a one more rank match?
Is that a Rashid mirror?
Do I get one more rank match?
No.
Shine plays Ed and Kimberly.
I know him for Kimberly.
I didn't know he was playing Ed.
Are you watching the Ed thing?
See what maybe... I don't know.
See what he does.
Yeah.
Let's take a look here.
Is Kimberly good in this patch?
No.
She's like a counter pick character.
She's a good tournament character too.
She can just play super fast.
She can just rush people down and rob them real quick.
Is it...
Should I just wait instead of playing another game?
You can get like one game.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we gotta go.
Wow, addicted.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I'm tired of the Street Fighter main menu music.
Yeah, you gotta turn music off.
Street Fighter 6 music is fucking ass.
It's so bad.
Yeah.
Compared to Tekken, I agree.
Tekken has the best.
Yeah.
I think...
Dude, Street Fighter music has been sucking for the past like two installations.
I think Street Fighter 4 music was sick.
4 had great music.
4 had fighting in Ed.
4 and 5 were... I preferred 4, but I think 5 was still pretty good.
A lot of people love 5, but 6 is...
It sounds like AI garbage.
Like it's crazy how bad it is.
It sounds machine generated.
Okay, it doesn't look like...
It doesn't look like he's doing any better.
Shine?
Because I feel like Rashid just does whatever he wants.
But yeah, that's...
The thing is, you guys can't judge anyone around like that.
In Street Fighter, you just get fucking mauled unless you guess right, and then you maul them.
It's a two-touch game, 100%.
Yeah, not necessarily the touches, just the momentum also.
Rashid doesn't really two-touch you, he just carries momentum forever and you're guessing.
No way, man.
Yeah.
It's so normal to see someone get fucking mauled and then win.
It's so...
It just happens.
Is Rashid arguably like top three or something?
I think Rashid's number one.
People will argue that.
I think he's number one.
Because I think he has extra mix that other characters don't have without meter.
He can do things that other characters can't.
And then level two is the best level two in the game.
Agreed.
See, he just got a bunch of plus frames for no fucking reason.
You know what I mean?
Other characters can't do this.
Why does he...
Why can he do this?
Because of DLC sales or what?
Are they doing it like Tekken?
He was like this in Street Fighter V also.
Street Fighter V obviously.
I have PTSD from SFV, Rashid.
Oh, nice level three.
That was sick.
You also did a cool one where they...
You leveled one, I think.
Yeah, for the DI.
That's so hard.
When you were stunned.
Oh, he burned himself out.
High level.
Nice.
This is actually a good spot for shine.
Yep, that's it.
That's crazy, man.
That's how it is, right?
He had to fucking scrap by nearly mauled Frio two rounds right there, right?
Yeah.
That's how this game is.
It's so exhausting, I swear, man.
I feel like it's all fighting games too.
Tekken is so tiring too now with the heat stuff.
I think that's like a lot of modern games.
They're like that.
They're so offensive.
I play Street Fighter IV for like...
I feel like I could play that for days.
And not get tired.
Oh, yeah.
It depends on who you're playing.
If you play like a good fucking Ibuki or some Viper, you're getting vortexed.
I get what you're saying.
I played Bison.
I played Juri and Reina.
I could play Reina all day, every day.
I love Reina.
Grinding a Mishima must be really fun, though.
So fun.
Wave-oo, wave-oo, wave-oo, electric.
Wave-oo, wave-oo.
Sidestep.
They combo.
Hellsweep.
Occasional hellsweep.
Hellsweep, hellsweep, hellsweep.
They never expect a third one in a row.
That's so true, that's so true.
Oh, god.
Wait, I might...
Oh, nice.
Oh, damn, I do it.
Uh-oh, coach.
Check him out.
Wait a minute.
Oh, he got it.
Nice jump.
Nice.
I felt like that was so obvious.
The DI attempt.
That might just be you.
Sometimes it may look obvious, and sometimes it's the best DI ever.
That's just me working.
That is up a game, damn.
Nice.
So, Legend starts at 2,000 or what?
No, no.
It's the moving target.
It's top 500.
And the problem with that is, like, also, there's inflation.
Japan has, like, all the points.
So, like, these guys might not even be Legend towards the end of the season because there's not enough players.
Oh, it's not region locked?
No, so they compare you with the whole economy, with the world, and there's, like, 40,000 times more players in Japan.
Can you imagine if that was Overwatch?
That would be really dumb.
So, at the end of the season, most NA players are not Legend because if they're in Asia, they would be.
That backdash was sick.
Does Apex region lock it?
No.
No, it doesn't.
Apex, it doesn't.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Okay, so it's like Apex in a way.
Wait, which one?
Is it Bones or Claire's invite?
I have two invites.
I think it's Claire's.
Is it Claire?
Okay.
I think so.
I'm not in there because I'm watching the Shine match.
Yeah, I think it's Claire's.
Oh, yeah, I'm in it.
We played this team, so you got time.
Yeah, we played Shine, yeah.
Okay.
He meet frame 1, P1.
Nice.
That's great.
I used to watch a lot of Shine for his Street Fighter 5 jury back when she was booty cheeks.
Yeah, Shine's been godlike for a long time.
Wait, what's their points right now?
Let's see.
What's their points?
Okay.
Oh, our team points?
It doesn't even tell me.
I don't think... did they post our team points?
There might be a form, but I don't know if it's updated.
Oh, there's a score tracker.
It's the news.
Oh, is it?
Okay.
I don't know how to read this.
I don't know how to read theory.
Wow, this is looking like a wash, man.
This is a lot of stuff.
Wow.
He did his thing.
It was crazy.
There's a current three-way tie at the moment.
Three-way tie?
Damn.
By who?
Us, JB, and Phone.
No, of course not, guys.
We're last.
What the fuck?
Nephew is first.
What the fuck, guys?
So close.
I should believe, dude.
I'm on that copium right now.
We're first, right?
We're all tied for fourth, guys.
Auto, Shine, and...
It's Neph, then Auto, and Shine.
Aren't we playing...
Auto...
Yeah, we're playing Auto and Shine.
Okay.
We're playing Auto and Shine next.
Is that who we're tied with?
No, we're tied with JB and Phone.
Okay, okay, okay.
We already played against them.
They're playing against Auto and Shine next.
Got it.
It's okay, guys.
Next Friday is where it matters, right?
We're all gonna grind so much.
Sunday is where it matters, dude.
No, we want the...
Okay, I don't know if we're gonna get the buy, but we want the better matchup.
We want a buy.
I think Nephew is definitely getting the buy.
No, it's the exact same.
Yeah, so we play everybody on Friday again, right?
It's worth more, though, the win.
Yeah, the five points.
Right.
Which matters.
Yeah, for sure.
Oh, no, I don't wanna leave.
That was an accident.
Do I need to do a coin flip?
If they don't request for it...
Did they ask for it?
Where?
Are you from North Carolina?
No.
That was random, though.
What do you mean?
I just see a lot of, like, UNC in your chat, so I don't know if you went to, like, University of North Carolina or something.
Did you go to UNC?
No, that's not why.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, it took me a second.
Oh, we can play one.
I'm in.
I just went to school there.
I don't live there, though.
Oh, okay.
I don't know if you're being serious.
Wait, did you really?
Oh.
Alright.
I went to UNC.
I don't think I can do the thing I like to do the most.
I think they're trolling SK.
I didn't get it.
UNC is UNCLE?
UNC?
They're calling him UNCLE.
Oh, you're called UNCLE?
Oh, shoot.
My bad.
No, yeah, yeah.
I always wondered...
I'm only 30, bro.
I mean, you could be an uncle.
I'm in my prime.
My brother's younger than me.
Oh, what?
Oh, I thought it was a dodge.
That makes a lot more sense now.
That was funny, though.
Oh, I keep forgetting that doesn't do the thing.
Oh, damn.
Sweep.
Oh, they're jumping.
Yeah.
I wanted to do the grab.
That would have been sick.
Nice.
What the fuck?
This is one bar.
Time for the Doki Zeme.
I just realized I'm one bar.
Oh, nice.
Let's go.
There's only one bar for this connection.
Oh, it's a one bar?
No shot.
There's only one bar for this.
It's okay.
You're playing GEEF.
Just GEEF them.
Let's go.
They're not reacting in one bar Wi-Fi.
I don't know.
I'm not reacting.
Doki Zeme, let's go.
Let's go.
Yeah, they're not ready for it.
Get them.
Okay.
Oh, they're doing the power move.
If he jumps at you, you can level three if he jumps at you.
Wait for it.
No, she's good.
You're good.
I think she knows I want to do it.
That's why.
No, she don't.
I got it.
My loyal fan.
Yo, jumps in.
I got it.
Gigachat.
Wait, do we not have the NA restrictions for this one?
It's okay.
Don't even worry about it.
I'm just like, holy fuck.
How do I process this?
No, the adaptation.
I'm not good at that part.
Okay.
All right, all right.
Oh, she's jumping a lot.
I just noticed.
There you go.
Analyze.
What?
That was all.
That should have worked.
It's the one bar.
I swear to God.
It's the lag.
Blame the lag.
Okay.
There you go.
Get him.
Okay.
Yes.
Here we go.
Okay.
No.
Oh, what?
I thought I blocked it.
Is that an overhead?
I think it is.
It's an overhead.
Okay.
Now that I know.
Nice.
You're cracked.
That was so good.
Cook him up.
Listen, it's nothing compared to Weed God.
Oh, that's true.
Weed God had Wi-Fi.
Oh, man.
I think she gets this.
There's no way I live.
Yeah.
I think you're dead.
All right.
Here we go.
1-1.
I don't think I can Larry it against...
I don't know.
I may be timing it wrong.
I could be timing it wrong.
All right.
Oh.
Yeah, it's tricky.
They can go other sides.
Nice.
Let's go.
Okay.
I know she jumps a lot.
Adapting.
Okay.
I know I can hit that.
But I can't hit the Lariat.
Do I have enough?
No.
Larry it?
He doesn't have the Lariat.
Almost.
Okay.
Nice.
Cook him up.
Do I get that?
Yes.
Okay.
I get that.
That's my goat.
I am almighty.
Holy.
No.
I pressed the triangle.
It's okay.
Yeah.
It was a misinput.
It was misinput.
They have no meter.
It's okay.
We take those.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're good.
You're a tank.
Oh.
Okay.
That's crazy.
I don't even get it.
I'm actually freaking out.
Because he jumps a lot.
Almost.
Almost again.
Did you?
Oh my god.
That was insane.
That was crazy dude.
Nice anti.
Out of the air.
Nice.
Here we go.
Get him.
Yeah.
Nice Lariat.
Let's go get him.
Can I get this?
No.
That should have been a hit.
A little too early.
That's alright.
Very close.
You have the game point.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
These air tires are crazy.
Cook up.
Cook him up.
Go.
Okay.
Man.
Don't keep...
This is neutral.
She does this thing.
Which is really...
Nice.
Yes.
Yep.
Grounded.
Yes.
Trying.
Oh my day.
Okay.
Yes.
Nice anti air.
Oh my god.
She has critical art.
Okay.
Be careful.
I got it.
Let's go.
Oh.
Technically I'm gold.
I mean I'm gold so I'm gold.
You're gold.
That was actually neutral.
You're right.
I'm gold rank.
That was neutral.
You were playing neutral.
How do you...
I almost fell over my chair.
With those air command.
I can't do the lariat.
But I can do air command.
Dude.
You did the lariat too.
Yeah.
Dude you're cooking dude.
They're not ready for Friday.
Now she'll never jump when she fights me.
What do I do?
Alright SK.
What do I do when she doesn't jump?
You win either way.
Alright.
Thank you Justin.
I did it.
Even if we don't get it it's fine.
Yeah.
No.
That's okay.
It'll be funny if we don't get it.
If we don't get it.
It's for content.
You know.
This is the learning ground Robin.
We're throwing for content.
It's fine.
Yeah.
We're throwing.
I wasn't even trying guys.
Oh nice DI.
Bleem.
Oh here we go.
Nice.
Oh she uses an ED.
Interesting.
They have two EDs.
Oh they do.
Yeah.
Oh the coach uses an ED.
They all wanted to play Shion's character.
Oh really?
That's so funny.
Don't worry it's Composure.
Okay.
What the hell?
Yeah it's Modern.
Oh I see.
Oh man.
Yeah their anti-airs are gonna be really good.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's time to learn Modern.
It's time.
Modern.
Isn't Nephew Modern Jurgie?
No.
He's Class A.
Okay.
Nice.
Good defense.
Oh nice.
That's good.
Good recognition.
Almost there.
Oh.
She's wave dashing.
Oh yeah.
Oh that's
a good combo.
Deliver Modern you.
Oh my goodness.
I can't jump.
Yeah jumping's not gonna be good against Modern players.
You saw what happened to Kanna.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Nice wake up.
Let's go.
That's my Grand Master Lucio.
You're getting there.
Oh wow.
Oh my god.
I won two rounds.
I think I beat my record from the last AJM.
Maybe you don't hate Street Fighter.
Maybe you don't hate it.
I'm still drinking tonight.
Okay.
Composure.
You're good.
Go live.
Probably the best level 3 in the game.
It's so cool looking.
Yeah it's alright.
It's alright.
You almost.
Is there one more round?
You can be more confident with the drive rushes.
Drive rush medium.
Drive rush overhead.
The jumping is not too good.
Against Ed.
I'm doing something.
What's that?
You're going Chun.
Oh they're not expecting this.
You should do Modern Chun Li.
Alright.
Cook them up SK.
Let's go.
Two hours of grinding.
Time for some safe John.
I have to spectate again.
Why doesn't it automatically...
Alright.
Because Capcom is too busy giving us Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Don't question Street Fighter developers man.
You'll never find any answers.
Oh nice.
Nice costume.
Oh shit the match started.
That's what we were just talking about.
Yeah dude.
I stowed out there.
There we go.
Ready for the speed guys.
Oh.
Oh wait a minute.
We gotta strat.
Oh my god.
Oh I did the jury combo instead.
It's fine.
You're cooking them up.
He was not prepared.
Okay.
No.
Nice.
Correct.
Let's go.
Is Chun-Li like the counter pick to Ed?
If it's working here then yes.
It's a mental counter pick.
It's a mental.
Oh okay.
Yeah they've been watching VODs of...
It could be a counter pick if she doesn't know.
Yeah they've been watching VODs of SK playing Jury but not Chun-Li.
That's fine.
You got the reset with the graph.
Nice.
Oh nice.
Let's go.
Another reset.
You're cooking.
It's okay.
No problem.
Maybe we should ask Huntress to coach you too.
The plan still works.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh nice.
Nice.
Got the lifeline.
No worries.
This is neutral.
By the way.
Which one?
Which part?
This right here.
Good defense.
Nice.
Let's go.
Confidence and control.
Yes.
You can tell you're more confident.
Let's go.
She does that wake up EX reversal a lot.
It's unsafe.
I hate it.
That's Ed's DP.
You can do your safe jump combo there.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
Yes.
Nice.
Reversal.
That was really good.
Nice.
Oh nice.
Get him.
Yeah.
Okay.
Composure.
We're good.
Okay.
Oh.
That was close.
That was a good jump back.
No worries.
Could have gone either way.
Yes.
This is close.
This is really close.
Maybe you should learn two characters.
That's impressive.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
Just blocking.
Oops.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh.
It's alright.
No.
It's not today.
Is she alive?
Sounds like an asshole.
Sounds like a cop.
What an anti-air actually.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
Here we go.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh.
Let's go.
Nice.
That's insane.
Composure.
Here we go.
Oh.
That was nice.
She's cooking.
Nice.
Let's go.
Get him.
Nice defense.
Yep.
You have a level three.
Let's go.
Nice.
Get him.
Yes.
Let's fucking go.
That's it.
Let's go.
Good job.
Oh my god.
The Chun-Li swap.
I told you.
You practiced that save jump.
I told you that shit would just loop on you.
You got it.
That was insane.
Dude.
You are nutty.
I had to use the bathroom.
But I was like...
What's the point of moving over lights?
While I was pissed and I was watching.
I'm like this shit is crazy.
Damn.
Let's go.
I didn't know how to leave because I've never won so I left the room.
Your first win.
Let's go.
My entire chat is thanking you SK for the channel points.
That was beautiful.
Exactly what you practiced.
That was awesome.
That was nutty.
I don't think they were ready for a save jump in C2.
That was crazy.
Oh my god.
I cannot believe it.
And then when they blocked it you did the fireball instead of the save jump again.
The combo.
I saw that SK.
That was clean.
I saw the high level play there.
I think you are supposed to be playing Hag-Li SK.
Oops.
Oh shit.
How are you burned out?
I don't know what happened.
What happened?
I don't know.
The match fast forwarded and you were burned out in 10 seconds.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
I missed it.
He's fine.
No you got those.
Did I burn out again?
I didn't see it guys.
It's okay.
Screw it dude for your loyal fans.
Did he win or no?
He did.
Okay.
I need the meter.
Dragon Ball Z 2.
Nice.
Wait why does this team have all adds?
There's a lot of adds actually.
Yeah.
Shouldn't you be coaching these guys?
And they all want to learn the level 2 combo.
You want your team to play different characters.
Not the same one.
Wait really?
That's not true because Brapo and I we won.
And we were all the same tier.
Oh you're right.
Yeah but we did this as a team.
King is very special too.
He's a special boy.
Oh okay.
Come on Brapo.
Nice.
Brother you're about to go undefeated today.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
I'm going to check in Roy.
He's always talking about this Roy motherfucker.
Like who cares?
No Roy is good bro.
He saw him in Tekken.
You should have seen him in Tekken.
It was not fun.
He's like in the discord like bro Roy.
You got to look up Roy.
Okay.
Roy is also undefeated.
So like one of you guys will be defeated.
You burned out.
Are you just fucking with him with the burnout?
He's definitely fucking with him.
He doesn't care dude.
He's going to burn out no matter what.
That's so toxic.
I saw that.
Holy shit.
Oh man it's styling right now.
Wait dude.
You know like the down O.
I don't play modern.
What are you talking about?
Holy shit.
Holy fuck.
You know if you want to BM.
She's notating in Sony bro.
That's crazy.
I can only read in controller symbols.
I can't read in anything else.
Yeah do that.
That's it.
You got these?
Okay here we go.
Oh nice.
Okay nice.
Empty jumper.
Let's go.
Somebody ban that guy.
This is not toxic.
It's just FGC.
American reset.
This guy is trying to fight me man.
He's trying to fight me.
Bro he's stepping up for his bro dude.
You should fight Bra Pro and then if he wins he gets to fight Ko.
Oh I like that.
I don't want to queue up.
Akuma time.
Sorry I queued up.
But I'm also spectating.
This privileged old man.
I swear to god.
Oh my god did I break Kanna's win streak?
Oh my god I did.
I'm looking at the scores.
Yeah she won every game except for me.
Let's go.
It's the power of Gief let me tell you dude.
Let's fucking go.
Bro he broke my retri.
Did that fast forward happen?
Yeah.
I love the fast forward.
The coefficient just beating ass.
Yeah that's perfect.
There we go.
Nice hug.
That was cheap.
That was hot.
That was hot?
I'll do that more for you.
No don't.
Every time you style you lose.
Just play to win.
But I wanna style.
Play to win.
That perfect is pretty stylish man.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Stop styling.
Nice safe jump yeah.
Don't worry about it.
Nice.
Get ready for the anti-airs.
Oh that's a good combo.
One more.
He went for it.
You're styling.
I see you styling.
That was for SK dude.
He was doing it for SK yeah.
What is she parrying?
Uh oh.
Her webs dude.
Oh okay.
Uh oh.
Time for a wake up situation.
You know what I'm gonna do something here.
Oh my god he's gonna wake up level 3.
And it's not gonna work.
It's not gonna work.
Alright it's gonna work dude.
All this shot right there.
Bing.
Farewell.
Dude I love this character.
This character is so sick.
Oh my god.
Can she do that to me?
Sorry.
Oh not that.
Maybe you should learn a third character.
SK.
I got you.
I'll help you.
Learn a third character.
One character for each round.
Yeah.
Learn modern Aki.
Nice.
That chop's so stupid.
Oh my god.
We gots in my chat.
He's cracked.
He doesn't know what to do.
Nice resets.
Uh oh.
He had to do reversal.
He was out of options.
Did you see how I styled right there?
I kinda like posed like Jojo.
Oh my god yeah.
It definitely wasn't a missed heavy.
No it was a pose.
It was the style.
Guys we gots in my chat and he's from the navy.
He's real.
We got preppy for that bison match.
He was like sorry.
I'm playing on navy wifi.
Oh my god.
I stopped the arc.
Oh.
I attacked.
Kuma thanks.
Don't worry about it.
Oh my god.
This character is dumb as fuck.
Nice block.
Now you're good.
You're good.
You're out.
Nice!
Oh that's good.
He doesn't block low.
Every overhead was blocked.
Every low you get a free combo.
It's good to know.
I just like that reset.
Wah wah wah.
Nice.
You know what to do.
Exactly.
Free combo every time.
He pays for the overhead.
Look at that.
Look at how much he pays for that.
Let's go baby!
Nice!
Let's go!
Oh that's good.
Perfect.
That's a 4-0.
Now the coach doesn't have to play.
This is what I need.
I don't want to have to play.
Oh shit wait.
My turn.
This is what you guys got to be doing.
Let's go!
Hold on Doki.
Give me a second.
Why are we fighting?
I don't want to throw hands with the bird.
Alright.
That training paid off coach.
Thank you.
No problem.
You're ready.
He wasn't blocking low at all.
Well I think Jordan on Friday is going to start blocking.
I start rubbing my hands.
I'm like yes.
Yeah Friday is going to be weird man.
I don't want like...
For people who won all of theirs it might suck more.
Yeah because they're going to analyze the vibes.
We'll just do the opposite on Friday.
We'll just overhead every time on Friday.
Yeah.
They're going to think I don't block.
But then on Friday I'm going to finally learn how to block.
Probably not.
Even though you paid $70.
Maybe like okay I'll block 10% more.
You're right I won't block.
Is this a Kimberly?
Yeah it's Shine.
Shine is like one of the best Kimberly's.
Probably the only Kimberly right now.
I don't know any other Kimberly.
Yeah but how many YouTube subscribers does he have?
Yeah exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
Does he have the plaque?
Didn't think so.
Damn that's...
That's fucked.
Bro that's fucked.
Oh damn.
I sped up into my coach getting beat up.
Jesus.
He's just teaching us what not to do.
Right?
That's basically what he's doing.
Look.
I'm telling you coach.
You should have had the piss buff.
Their coach is avenging their players right now.
After everything we did.
Let's go!
Fuck it.
We ball.
Let's go.
Oh shit.
That's cool.
Oh my gosh.
Do it again!
Get him brother!
That's alright.
He guessed right.
He's not dead.
It might be a pixel.
It's a pixel for sure.
It's dangerous.
Will it kill?
It did not kill.
She's listening to music.
That's illegal.
She's about to get DMCA'd real soon.
Yeah.
Ah fuck.
I sandwiched beneath the fucking ball.
Yeah the paintbrush dude.
Oh yeah.
Looking at the scores for the others.
One of our.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
Nice.
I am tired.
Woo.
Oh.
What are you doing glowing green?
Nice.
Oh nice.
That shimmy attempt.
That was too.
Yeah.
Okay.
Trying to check that so hard.
Nice.
That's cool.
Okay.
Doki this is neutral right here.
This one?
You say that every match.
This is neutral.
I'll never know what neutral is.
Let's go.
I'll never turn.
Stand still.
Coach is the cop dude.
Is this neutral?
No not yet.
Okay this is neutral.
This right here.
This is neutral right here.
You see this?
Okay.
Does the game only have neutral?
Or is there anything else?
Every game has neutral.
There's no such thing as no neutral.
What's it called when it's not neutral?
Guys I think we're making our coach throw.
I think.
I'm sorry.
I lost the neutral.
He lost the neutral.
See what I mean?
Wait how did you lose the neutral?
If everything is neutral.
Cause he's guessing wrong.
If you think about it.
I made a mistake.
Now it's neutral.
That was neutral?
Neutral is one big coin flip.
Sometimes it's heads.
Sometimes it's tails.
Okay.
He called heads and he got heads.
Wait so it's fighting games?
Just gotcha?
You get that SSR conversion?
Yeah.
Are you going to get that SSR ball?
Hold on.
We'll see if coach gets it.
Coach gets lucky here.
Oh my god you're going to get a waifu?
Alright nice.
That was like an SR.
Oh here we go.
Okay here we go.
Nice check.
Nice.
That's it.
That's an SSR right there.
You see that?
Side step right?
Nice.
Side step right.
I'm so sorry you're in this.
I know you want to play Tekken so bad.
I believe in the Brian.
DOS.
Let's go DOS.
Did you guys see that?
No I looked away.
Can you do that again?
You only look when I'm getting smoked.
I'm looking away.
I'm looking away right now.
What the hell?
I thought you were safe.
Is he winning?
I looked away.
Actually he might be.
Hold.
It's not over.
Okay I'm still looking.
Doki turn it off.
Okay.
Shut it down.
Okay I'm looking away.
Sorry.
Don't worry coach.
Composure.
We're good.
Ignore the birds.
Don't worry coach.
They're down four games.
If it makes you feel any better.
Their entire team lost.
Guys but we need the points.
We need to catch up.
We can't be last.
Coach we gotta pay rent dude.
Come on man.
Coach.
This is our only job.
I'm unemployed coach.
Please.
Time to hit that unemployment.
This is our 9 to 5.
Come on.
Come on food stamps again.
GG's.
Good try.
Yeah GG's coach.
That was good.
This is the strap you guys just took.
And then we're good.
Sorry that was my bad.
This is the first group that we actually like.
It was always 2-2.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
The official Street Fighter account retweeted my stream.
That's cool.
They're cloud chasing.
They literally have more Twitter followers than me.
What do you mean?
God damn Capcom do cloud chasers.
That's what they are dude.
Actually.
We have to go to another room now.
Yeah the last team we're playing.
Oh yeah.
You finally get to play Roy.
Automatic.
Can we just tell them to play the Roy match now?
So we can get in home.
Bro is anxious.
Can we make that request?
I'm going to make that request.
I'll be like, Bro really really wants to fight Roy first.
It's fine.
Were you laying in bed just thinking about the conversions you can get on Jamie?
I don't know any bro.
I don't fucking know any.
You got him knocked down.
Thinking in your head.
Oh man I should drive.
I want to play this.
So I can like study it for tomorrow.
You know what I mean?
Even if I win.
I want to see what that character has.
He's so annoying in ranked.
He's really.
He is annoying.
What's your weakness?
Yeah.
Heavy punch is obnoxious.
When I heard that button is 5 frames.
I nearly shat my pants.
Yeah.
So that can come out randomly if you're just spamming it.
But it's negative on block.
Unless they dry brush into it.
You kind of have to let him dry brush a little bit here and there.
With the heavy punch.
Cause that shit is too quick.
Wait.
What's the weakness for Aki?
Cause I'm fighting an Aki next.
You're fighting an Aki?
She has bad defense.
She doesn't have a DP.
Wait I'm going to knowledge check her.
Yeah knowledge check her.
What does that mean?
When you say that Doki.
I'm going to back triangle.
You give me a little nervous.
Let's switch back triangle.
I'm back triangle.
She's got a full screen running bear.
If she doesn't block then I'll know.
Like I said Doki.
You get one.
I know I always do one.
I do it once.
If it doesn't work.
The thing is I do that for today.
Cause then I'll know.
They'll never let me do that again.
Like...
Or just do it closer.
That's the only difference.
Do it up close to them.
Not point blank.
But a little bit close.
That's actually really scary.
I think you should do that more actually.
If they throw snob bubble at you.
Just lariat.
Oh dark soul dodge it.
Yeah dark soul dodge it.
I frames.
I frames it.
I feel like that's more like a bloodborne dodge.
That's if they try to run at you through it.
Otherwise you can just block it.
I don't know if this person will do that.
Normally they throw the snob bubble and they run at you.
I don't know either.
Everybody keeps yelling me to do headbutt.
But I keep forgetting.
Yeah that's the best part.
If you jump in on them.
If you can learn headbutt for Friday.
Like you'll.
You're cooking.
I don't know like when is the best time.
I always get nervous on when the best time is.
Whenever you're up close.
Like if you get a knockdown and you're close to them.
And you don't have the dry rush up.
That's when you do it.
So the ones from far away you're doing the right thing.
Like you're dry rushing in that's fine.
But if you're already point blank when they're knocked down.
That's the best thing to do is just headbutt.
I'm back with hot water.
Nice.
Hot water.
You're 7 plus and minus.
I almost failed math.
Which math?
I don't know.
You don't have to worry about all that.
We're here to crunch the numbers for you.
It's a plus too.
I was like what the fuck does that mean?
You gotta keep pressing your triangles.
Bashing your squares.
It'll be okay.
Red 4.
Blue 3.
She said I failed math.
I almost.
I passed barely.
And I had to map tutors like every other day.
And I still almost failed.
Dude.
Every other day.
No it's true.
I would have like 2 hour tutors.
Because I was like almost unsalvageable.
D's get degrees.
You understand?
It's fine.
You can still learn as much as possible.
I thought it was C's.
D's bro.
America is something else.
Let me tell ya.
He's at my stage.
Damn.
Where do you live brother?
Yeah.
I never heard of that.
I don't know what school coefficient went to.
Dude.
I'm in.
I'm in the good old.
He went to UNC.
Is that that?
I didn't know what UNC meant dude.
I don't know what that means.
And SK had a wonderful education.
I dropped out.
I got a degree.
But it had nothing to do with math.
Bro I dropped out too dude.
I'm with you SK.
Damn.
We need that 50k Brian.
I'm telling you bro.
I mean it when I say I gotta pay rent.
You guys need money or something?
This is our hobby right?
Brian you're off the clock after 8pm PST please.
Wait coach.
Coach real talk.
Real talk can I ask you something?
Do you think I can kill someone with fang bubble?
Which move is that?
So her taunt.
She blows a fang bubble.
And it blows it behind her.
Doesn't that take like 3 minutes to come out?
Close.
But yeah.
Then probably not.
But if you land it it'll be fucking sick.
I just don't think it's gonna happen.
I'd rather you just do driver's blow and win.
Over and over.
Dude I'm...
It's so sick.
Wait did they already invite us?
No they said they're going to.
They added us.
My bad.
Wait are they still playing?
I'm gonna go grab some water guys.
Oh we just got the code.
Okay yeah we got it.
I have to fight my wife.
Who?
Who's your wife?
Gatling.
Yeah.
Yeah how's she doing so far?
She's doing really well.
She was 2-1 last night.
1-2-1-2-0.
Who does she play?
Modern Ken.
Oh good luck.
No no pick Chon.
You should go with Chon.
They might have studied your jury so.
She's lost too.
So...
She lost Bright Shield.
And...
Uh...
Skara.
Oh Skara's too powerful.
He keeps command grabbing everyone.
Skara's doing good.
He's good man.
I'm surprised cause Manaan's not great.
But I guess I end flat.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
So are you playing Chon SK?
I don't know.
You should do it for the Evo moment you know.
I think I go jury and see if she has the anti-airs.
And if she does.
Then I go Chon.
Oh that's a good idea.
Or if you want to throw her off right now.
Just play Chon.
Yeah the other way around.
Yeah you can throw her off right now.
Yeah see if she has the DI reactions.
And if she does I go jury.
Yes.
Decisions.
Are you all in the lobby?
Yeah I'm in the lobby.
They're not set up yet.
Oh they said you guys can start when ready.
Yeah you can start when ready Doki.
I'm waiting.
I forgot that you're frame one sitting down.
MP1 side.
I already fucking locked that in.
Yeah Nephew's first.
Nephew's definitely first.
Yeah Nephew's cracked.
Yeah I appreciate it.
I think Nephew won all their coach games.
Yeah.
2-1, 2-1.
Someone said he's like top 15 in the world or something.
Like what the heck is that?
He should be nerfed.
He should like play blindfolded or some shit.
Like.
To average it out.
If you're top 500 in Street Fighter.
You need to like nerf yourself.
Play a different character.
That's not fair.
That's like the PG-13 version of like.
Love yourself.
It's true.
If you're top 500.
You should have like one nerf.
Bro.
The LTG emote with nerf yourself is too good chat.
Good job.
Nerf yourself now.
Knowledge check time.
See I told you.
It's knowledge check.
I have to spectate.
Does that mean it works?
That looks so stupid.
Now I know it doesn't work.
Oh.
Alright.
I gotta see this.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh.
Get him.
He crashed my armor.
Okay.
Get him.
The triangle.
That was crazy.
Good job.
Let's go.
That move you can just.
Super unsafe.
Oh.
Nice jump.
He didn't get up.
Let's go.
You don't need my help.
You're cooking.
Get him.
We take those.
Okay.
Nice.
Let's go.
Made for modern.
This is incredible.
Oh.
That was a good idea.
That's the only way to beat that move.
Really?
Yeah.
She's all good.
She's classic.
She's really trying.
That's awesome.
Oh.
She grappled me.
Sad.
Did I hit that?
Oh.
Okay.
My loyal fans.
Anything on the ground in front of you.
That is free range.
She was crouched.
When she was crouched.
I couldn't tell.
Doki, I'm just letting you know.
Some people are not going to sleep tonight because of you.
Just letting you know.
I'm not going to sleep because of the hype.
Yeah.
I'm too excited.
Oh, my God.
Roy is going to be in his nightmares.
He's going to have Cheerios.
She's so fast sometimes.
R-O-Y.
He might smoke them.
I don't know.
It's just funny.
We'll see.
That's like the pay-per-view match of the night, dude.
It's a Jamie thing.
It's not a Roy thing.
Whatever you say.
Good job, Doki.
They're talking so much shit.
They forget to say good job.
Oh, yeah, by the way.
Oh, no.
I don't think I live this.
No, Doki.
Oh, nice.
Get him, Doki.
Unleash the demons.
I messed up.
I got worried.
Doki, just Lariat if it was flat.
Just Lariat after.
Yeah, down triangle.
Gotta react to it, too.
Oh, what?
You can do that?
Only one hit.
Oh, what's that?
That's a full screen thing.
If she doesn't hit it, you just grab her.
Okay.
Oh, ow.
Nice.
There you go.
I have to play slow.
I don't like it.
She doesn't know he plays fast.
You'll be rewarded soon.
Oh, yeah, the corner is upon us.
The corner is upon us.
You got her corner, so now you can go ahead.
She's there.
All right, time to party.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I fucked it up.
No, you're good.
You're good.
Oh, my God.
Let's go.
Get him.
Yep, Lariat.
Yep, there you go.
Can I get this?
Nice.
Oh, I do.
Let's go.
Can I get this?
I don't know.
That's the quote of the day, to be honest.
Every time she does it.
That's fucking right.
Do I get this?
You're so innocently doing these gnarly level 3s.
You really are stealing their souls when you do that.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you're rewarded.
You're at the corner now.
Time to party.
Yeah.
Oh, she counted it.
Yeah, she's adapting.
That was good on her.
That's fine.
She won't count on the next one.
Okay.
I would just do it again.
I like that.
Just do it again.
Exactly.
See?
I would just do it again.
Oh, unlucky.
It's alright.
There you go.
Give her a little one-two.
Nice.
And then Lariat.
Yes.
Oh, she counted it, too.
That's okay.
You're still alive.
Wait, am I going to die to this?
No, no, no.
You're not dying.
Oh, she did the far away one.
Oh, no!
I died.
Yeah.
We still got one more.
Is there an auto-combo she can do in the corner at all?
It's bad.
Uh, yeah.
But not after really the wall splats.
Oh, okay.
What did you say, SK?
Oh, I trained myself so hard.
When someone in this game DI's, I'm pressing my pinky down and my hands are even on my desk.
Beautiful.
Dude, I saw your psycho training.
Oh, she's just, uh, she's countered.
Yeah, we have to not do it as much.
Okay, now it's finally time to just walk up and triangle.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh, that was an accident.
Hahaha.
Nice.
Okay, yeah.
I keep forgetting that.
Sorry.
Oh, what?
That should've been hit.
Oh, nice.
That's alright.
Oh, what?
That was a grab.
Mmm, I saw the vision, yeah.
It would've worked.
Nice!
That was fixies.
Okay.
Well, I'm dead here.
No, no, no.
You got a chance.
You got this.
You gotta believe.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
You gotta believe!
Hell yes.
Perfect command grab.
Okay.
Let's go!
You gotta believe!
Okay.
The Doki Seme!
Let's go!
Ooh!
Nice.
Dude, just jump.
Don't do anything and grab.
That'd be so funny.
Whoops.
That was an accident.
Whoa.
Oh, that's my bad.
Whoops.
I'm panicking.
Hahaha.
Cool.
Keep it cool.
You got it.
Nice.
There you go, Lariat.
Oh, we did it.
Let's go!
You got it!
Yay!
Broke another record!
Let's go.
The power of Gief, dude.
You played so good.
You played neutral.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Your neutral was immaculate, Doki.
Good job.
You jumped over her slide and then you SCD'd her after.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Hahaha.
That's okay.
Stuff just happens.
Some words eat down inside.
You understand.
Stuff just happens.
Wait, why am I queuing for fucking...
What the fuck is going on, dude?
Wait, why are you queuing up?
Because you're next.
You throwing hands too?
Wait, is this me again?
No, it's SK.
Oh, leave queue.
There we go.
Are you playing Chun-Li, SK?
Am I fighting Bra Pro?
Yes.
No, no, no.
Who is Bald Icon?
That's not me.
If you beat him, you're literally a gold player.
No, this should be Cat Link?
No, it's Cat Link.
Knowledge Trigger.
Bald Icon came in.
It's missing as the sound effects.
Oops.
God, I hate Ken and Ken Player.
We fight so many.
I know.
Ken Player made me lose my mind last night.
I was really upset.
Nice, Zanchu.
Oh, it's time.
Nice.
Don't let her follow the flowchart.
Whatever that is.
I just stole what my chat said.
Nice parry.
What's the flowchart?
Alright.
Now all Ken Players eventually play.
How do they play?
You'll know it when you see it.
We haven't seen it yet.
Okay.
Kenathan is a menace.
Oh, nice.
There it is.
Nice.
It's okay, it's okay.
They're in the corner.
It's okay, you're on P1 side.
Nice!
And a punish.
Let's go.
That was so good.
Hadouken, Hadouken.
Nice!
Let's go!
Oh my god, that psycho training paid off, dude.
Nice.
She's burnt out.
Air to air.
To the corner, let's go get em!
You undid level 3!
Oh, it's alright.
You don't need a level 3.
We're saving it for next game.
It's okay.
We're saving the level 3 for next game.
For Friday.
You got it.
You were just teabagging.
We're just being toxic, that's good.
Damn.
We're gonna be the heel of Seijan Slam 3.
It's mental warfare, you understand?
Every tournament needs a heel and that's us.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay, they're waiting for that.
She flippin'.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I'm so mad at my wife right now.
That's right.
Take the house and the divorce!
Okay, you're doing good.
Nice!
That was cheesy.
It's all good, it's all good.
Nice punish.
Nice grab.
Get em.
Oh no, is that the flowchart?
Oh yeah.
They're honestly not flowcharting.
Nice.
Oh, that's close, that's close.
Solid round.
Wait, is this the second match or the second round or the third round?
This is the second game.
Okay.
So yeah, SK's up.
Okay, I've been losing track.
They're actually playing neutral, so it's taking a while.
Is this neutral?
No, not yet.
This is the part after neutral.
Not yet, not yet.
This is what happens after neutral.
When they're doing nothing and you forget what game it is, that's when they're playing neutral.
Oh, okay.
When you start spacing out and forget what's going on, that's neutral.
I was throwing there.
Wait, I'm throwing.
Oh shit, I think it's time to bring out the jury after this.
Oh, okay.
No, I think that's fine.
So do you want to take a quick break, SK?
Like go back to the lobby?
Do it.
I think if I go jury I'm just going to get fireballed out.
No, no, you don't need to go jury, you can just take a break.
Yeah, yeah.
Is that ethical?
It is.
No!
It's okay, Composure.
You're good, you're good.
Just plug and be like, sorry my internet went off.
How would they know?
Can you even turn off your stream for a little bit?
To sell the ice.
Uh oh.
Oh man.
I actually
want P1 for China and I forgot.
Is that good?
Oh, I'm on P1.
Nice, you're on P1, you're fine.
Oh, that was a good dodge.
What the fuck am I watching?
That goes low.
Thanks.
That's Ken's flowchart right there.
Yeah.
Nice.
I figured it out.
Used to be Shuriken, now it's Jinrai.
Ow.
Oh damn, she got those.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Yeah, that's very punishable.
Good job.
It's time for the level 3 critical hit.
Nice.
Not now.
Oh, she doesn't care.
Oh, she's...
A lot of them might have hit.
It'll hit eventually.
Good try.
Yeah, they timed up.
They knew when to press after.
Like your Hanzanshu, that's their turn.
When they block it, they understood how to...
Can I skip this?
I don't wanna fight this guy, man.
It's time.
Bro, I'm getting the popcorn now.
This is gonna be good.
After everything you said about this guy's time.
Guys, at least...
I'm just gonna...
At least if we lose all the games today, we're not last.
Alright.
That's all that matters.
Not last.
Just yet.
Show them pearly whites, dude.
He's smiling at you.
You gonna take that?
Alright, these are the two top dogs.
The two undefeated players.
Let's see it.
Nice.
Get him.
Whoa.
Oh, yeah.
Keep him in the corner.
Don't let him drink.
Nice jabs.
Uh-huh.
Mmm.
Okay.
No.
He's drunk.
Nice.
Good punish.
Let's go.
Oh, the punish down here.
Okay.
That was risky for him.
He's definitely studying your vibes.
That's his uppercut on block, so it looks weird.
But...
Oh, that was close.
Time to attend the AA meeting, dude.
No more drinking.
This is an intervention.
Oh, no.
He needs one more drink.
Two more.
I can't count.
I forget.
You almost killed Matt.
I forgot.
I was there.
I was almost there, right?
Yep.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Good defense.
Let's go.
This...
See, that was neutral.
That was...
He's waiting for my knee.
Yeah, they were looking at each other.
And also, he's jumping at you a lot.
And he's also getting...
Once he lands one jump in from a distance that you could have lariated, he's going for cross-ups a bunch.
So, just make sure to focus on the far jump in and get the lariat.
Nice.
Damn it.
Every time I do something, he does a stupid kick.
You could use more stand MP.
You know, stand BD punch.
Stuff like that.
Maybe stand MK.
Like your pokes.
And then just be wary of the jump.
Oh my god.
Every time I go for the Polar Express, he fucking hits me.
The Polar Express.
This is like the slowest I've ever seen Brawl Pro play for the tournament.
I can't...
Yeah, he's like spacing you out so well.
Test his anti-airs.
You can do jump medium kick.
He plays...
He's a street fighter.
He plays Tekken.
He's very, very slow.
You gotta walk him down with better pokes.
Stand MK for you.
Represent these a little bit.
You're just backing up without doing anything.
Okay.
He's slowing you down so much that you're not used to it.
That's how Roy plays in general.
He's just very slow.
Wait until you mess up.
Nice.
There you go.
Get in there.
Oh, nice.
There you go.
Party time.
You're learning.
Oh, damn it.
I fucked it up.
It's okay.
I believe.
What the fuck?
Command grab.
He got assailed on you.
I mean, I don't even know what I...
I know it's a command grab, but I don't know the setup.
I've never seen that before.
I think he gets that at level 2 or level 3.
Nice.
Damn.
GGs.
Okay.
Yeah, I see what you're scared of.
We gotta figure out how to assert neutral a little bit more.
And then also, he was kinda disrespecting your Oki like crazy.
We gotta tighten that up.
He was jumping back a lot.
I didn't think he kept...
He was avoiding the light kick into Oki after knockdowns because he would just jump back.
Right.
But then I only adapted to that at the very end and then he didn't do it anymore at the very end.
And then when you got that SBD Oki, he was just like mashing.
I think you do drive, rush, crouch, MK to keep it nice and tight and easy.
Just to counter hit him to keep him pinned down.
Stuff like that.
The safest guaranteed options.
We gotta work on those.
Okay.
Got it.
Alright.
Who's the next person?
You're also back rolling every time.
Which didn't matter that much because he didn't take advantage of it.
But against Jamie, quick rise.
Because you don't want to give up space.
How do you quick rise?
I don't know how to fucking...
Don't press anything.
If you press kicks or you're mashing, you'll get a back roll.
If you don't press anything...
Oh, it's another DJ.
You're used to fighting against that.
Got it.
Holy shit, all that parry.
Row looping.
Nice defense.
Whoa.
BEP now.
Nice.
Oh, wow.
Nice combo.
Nice.
Nice comeback.
Fucked up by being iffy.
Just want to slither, bro.
Nice.
Sneaky throw.
Oh, nice.
If he doesn't know it, you gotta grab him.
Nice and easy.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Well done, dude.
Let's go.
Cool.
I can take on this DJ.
I can take him on.
You should...
Maybe you want to swap with him?
How do you feel about Jamie?
No, they should bump Roy up.
Maybe Roy should swap.
Why?
I know he lied on that application.
Whoa!
Live on stream?
Damn.
Clip it, guys.
RobPro calls Roy a fucking liar.
He's calling...
What's that word when you, like, fill, like...
Put yourself lower rank?
I'm just gonna go with that.
Put yourself lower rank in the tournament?
Smurfing?
Oh, Roy's smurfing.
RobPro calls out Roy for smurfing.
I do not know that word.
Don't you play Overwatch?
No, there's, like, a word...
Isn't there a word for, like, when you sign up for a tournament?
Sandbagging, I think?
Putting your rank as, like, lower than what it actually is?
Might be sandbagging.
I don't remember.
Could be.
Nice.
Good defense.
Lying.
Matt said lying.
You just want Kota to fight Roy.
Nice.
RobPro, you're really good at people who are very aggressive.
The moment they slow down, it's...
It's hard.
He's a good character, too.
You know, he has to do it carefully, I think.
One more.
Yes!
Is that gonna do it?
It's gonna be close.
Nice.
Easy!
2-2.
All right, coach.
Pretend this is the finals.
You have to win or we're not getting... we're not going to TwitchCon.
Have you ever heard of the concept of, like, no pressure?
To play better?
Pretend your family's all kidnapped, and you're gonna be murdered if you don't win this set.
Well, we're prepping you now.
We're training you now to handle pressure for Sunday.
I've never played in a high-pressure environment.
Yeah, like, on Sunday, you're gonna have to deal with the same things, so we're giving it to you now, so you're used to it.
It's like we're in a tournament or something.
The other coaches don't have this kind of training.
Just letting you know.
You'll be ready.
You're gonna crack on Sunday.
So you ready to play, Ko?
I got it, actually.
I got it.
We're all waiting for you.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, it's a nice Jamie.
That's why he's so good.
His coach is a Jamie.
Automatic is, like, a really technical Jamie.
He leveled up, too, a lot.
It was funny, because I was talking to him.
He's like, I can't beat the pro.
This sucks.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, God.
Jamie's so obnoxious.
He's not up there in the tiers, but he's really obnoxious.
He is.
I hate playing S in the rank.
Me, too.
Yeah, I hate finding him in the rank, too.
Is he hard to play?
Is that it?
So, his moves...
There are certain moves that get unlocked the more he drinks.
Yeah.
Oh, if he has no drinks, he's kind of like, whatever.
So, it's up to the Jamie player to drink more.
Yeah, to make him drunk.
Yeah, but once he gets, you know, he becomes, like, a really strong character the more he drinks.
You just have to stop him from drinking.
But he has really good buttons, like, really obscure type moves that isn't really fun to deal with.
Yeah, he's burnt out.
It's time to go in.
Get in the corner.
Nice.
Yeah!
All right, let's see if he has a...
Does he have a kill combo here?
I think he does.
Oh, yeah.
Bam, bam.
Bam, bam, bam.
Yeah, fuck that guy.
It was close.
I maybe could have killed him level two.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you gotta secure it.
It's not worth the risk.
You're good.
Yeah, this is Sunday.
We literally need one more point to win to go to TwitchCon.
No pressure.
Seriously.
It's Sunday.
It's tiebreaker Twitch fight.
Tiebreaker!
We're fighting for fourth place so we can go to TwitchCon.
It's all right.
He's bending early.
Oh, he's gonna burn him out.
Yeah.
Let's see here.
Oh, God.
The throat goat, dude.
Oh, that did like no damage.
Yeah, this is where it gets hard.
Oh, here we go.
Give him a chance.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
He doesn't have any resources.
He's not gonna do much.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We're going to TwitchCon!
Let's go!
Wait, we have one more set, right?
No, we have one more.
But we still cheer.
We still cheer.
Yeah, we still cheer.
That was Sunday.
Let's go!
Oh, good confirm.
Holy shit.
Nice tech.
Ooh.
Oh,
he ledged across.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh, that's gonna be so sick.
Woo!
Nice!
Call that shit out.
Oh, yeah!
Get him!
Yeah!
Put him in the corner!
Let's go, coach!
That's him!
I know that guy!
That's T-O-F right there.
Oh, nice punish.
Holy shit.
Level 2 time?
The bottom!
Let's go, baby!
Oh, my God.
These combos are so cool.
That is so sick, dude.
Oh, my God.
Wait, maybe... I have an idea.
Brawl Pro should learn Ed just for...
I don't have time.
Just learn Jamie.
Just learn Ed for the Jamie matchup.
That's all you need to know.
Uh-oh.
Hold on.
Wait, does he... Oh.
Yeah, so he gets instantly drunk when he does...
But his hair is still tied up.
Yeah, but his shirt's open.
See his shirt?
His shirt is open.
Oh, here we go!
Get him!
Kill him, coach!
Bring it home!
Let's go!
Twitch, let's go!
End the day with a win.
We did it!
We're going to Korea!
The kidnappers let your family go!
Here we go.
Hell yeah.
GG's.
Yay!
Did we beat this team overall?
What was our record?
We tied with...
We tied with Shine's team.
Wait, isn't this...
I think we won 3-2.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's 3-2, yeah.
So basically you won it for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we're basically...
Oh, it's a three-way tie between us, Bone, and Shine.
I don't know if that's updated, though.
For a second.
Oh, thank god.
First is Nephew.
They have 51 points.
Second, three-way tie is 36 points.
Jeez-a-loo, man.
Yeah, Nephew is a problem.
That's what I'm saying!
We need a Nerf Nephew!
Nerf yourself now!
Well, his team...
Nerf himself now.
Yeah, it's not a solo thing, right?
For me, I just lost every...
The games that are, like, counter-picked to Geve.
Because, like, Lillian and Lampo.
But there's key things.
Like, with most of our matches, there's very small things that we can pick apart real quick and, like, quickly identify.
Like, I'm pretty confident in a lot of these sets that we can all get more wins.
Like, very easily.
So I think, even though we're not in the lead...
So, did this update?
Are we tied for last?
We're tied for second.
It's a three-way tie.
Where is it?
Tied for second?
It's on the news.
If you go to the news and then you look at the score tracker.
But I don't know if that's updated.
That's the thing.
I don't know if it's updated or not.
How many points does it say we have?
36.
We have 36 points.
Is that accurate?
Okay, let's see.
Well, they didn't, on the challenge, they didn't update it.
I think.
Yeah, they did it.
I think that was a really good first run.
Yeah, we did pretty well.
Honestly, I was very surprised for myself.
I think we all did really good.
Yeah.
It says 39 points on mine.
Oh, maybe... Refresh?
Your coach, Brian, was...
Oh, we got second officially!
We're both second!
Wow, dude.
That's really good.
What the hell?
I know, like, Ko and SK, you both put a tier above what you put on the application.
That's pretty good for second place.
Wait, what are you talking about?
What?
Wait, you literally tweeted that!
Hold on a minute.
Friendly liar?
Why am I a liar?
Hold on a second.
No, I meant like you got placed, like, above because you were diamond when you started.
It's just like you don't really look like a master rank player coefficient.
I don't know.
No, I meant you're really good!
It's surprising how good you are coefficient.
Yeah.
Are you a fighting game streamer coefficient?
No.
Oh my god, it almost looked like you were a fighting game player.
Well, shit.
No, I just, I mean, I was, I just don't really play this game too much.
No, you're cooking, dude.
You did great.
I think I'm carried by Aki, real talk.
You got your flowchart, though.
You know how to implement a flowchart and execute it.
Like, that was really good.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm cheating too because, like, I watched Broski's guide and that guide literally, it was like giving me every single tool in the armory and I'm like, oh man, I don't even have to look for it.
It's just all there.
That's good.
Yeah.
I watched all three hours.
It was crazy.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
I sat here in this chair and I watched all three hours.
Oh my god.
We'll work on, so BrawlPro, we just gotta figure out how to, what to do if you're getting lamed out, which I think is a poke.
Doki, we just gotta figure out a few key moves.
Like, Blanka command grab and a couple other moves.
You just need to see the animation a bit more.
We can go over that and then we'll smoke them.
I just need a block.
You just have to have the reaction.
The blocking was okay.
I mean, your defense could be better but I just think there's a few moves that caught you off guard because you've just never seen them.
Yeah, I don't bump into Blanka or Lily.
I bumped into every other character in my division except for Blanka and Lily.
So it's really hard to... Right.
So you can't be expected to know what to do if you've never freaking seen the character.
Yeah.
So now we know a few things to just dial in.
We can drill the moves and then you can just see them and react to jump or you know, lariat, whatever.
And Eskay, you're cooking too.
I think the only thing is we gotta work on which character you wanna play for what matchup.
We can decide that.
And then I see a few sequences that are gonna be easy for you to clean up on.
Like after Hazanshu, what to do there.
So I think that when they knew what to do after your Hazanshu, that's when they...
That's when they can give you trouble.
I would like go for the lightning legs but then I get punished really hard.
Yeah, cause Hazanshu is actually negative.
Yeah.
Right.
I thought it was plus the heavy.
Uh...
The heavy?
No.
Oh.
Nevermind.
Not bad.
Now you're making me trip.
No.
Heavy Hazanshu?
Hazanshu, yeah.
It's minus two.
Oh.
Yeah.
It's minus two.
That's really bad.
I've been mashing up the risk.
I'm looking at the score sheet and I was the only one that beat Sykkuno which is pretty funny.
You didn't only beat him.
That's the only one.
No, I'm pretty sure I just tilted him so hard cause I kept bumping him into rank.
So he's just tilted at fighting me.
He sent you hate mail also.
He sent me hate mail about Thank you.
He just really hates Zangief.
He doesn't know what to do.
You gotta understand that you are the most terrifying person in this entire event.
But then they're playing Black Gun Lily.
Lily's not terrifying.
They're annoying.
But they're not terrifying.
You have a terrifying character and I don't even think you realize how scary you are.
Very scary.
You gotta embrace that power.
Nice.
That was fun.
I think if I wasn't king on my very first game I might be the navel.
I don't even know why you did that.
I don't know how that...
I don't know.
I tried to say.
Sometimes you gotta learn through experience.
It's okay.
I threw in round one.
It would've been bad if I installed king during the finals.
I gotta use the bathroom.
You should add Gumi and be like I threw in round one just to let you know.
No, if I really want to be toxic I threw in round one and I'm still second.
Oh shit!
Get him!
It wouldn't be that toxic.
That would be toxic, dude.
Wait, it updated.
We're 39 it says now.
We're officially second.
We're full second.
Oh, nice.
That's why we're talking.
That's why we're talking shit.
Let's go.
No, you won a game.
You won the Chun-Li mix up.
Yeah.
Chun-Li mix up.
And your division is like demon hours.
So it's like...
So many hours.
They put you in a fucked up division.
Yeah, they did.
This is your first time playing Street Fighter ever, right?
Yes, I have 40 hours.
Yeah, you're doing amazing.
You're being thrown to the Sharks right now who have actually been playing this game.
And you're playing Chun.
Chun is hard.
Chun is a hard character.
Thanks guys.
If it makes you feel better, you're working way more than they are.
These people don't know a good day's work when they see one, alright?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm watching your opponents and they have some flowchart shenanigans that the characters at their level are much easier at doing than Chun.
You picked a really honest character for picking up.
Locking injury on Friday.
I'll break down what they're cheesing you with.
Yay!
How much was each win worth today and what is it worth on Friday?
Three points and five points.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I think tomorrow we can like VOD review the matches.
I'm available all day tomorrow.
Me too.
We can all get on a call and kind of just VOD review everything.
I'll be available, you know, evening.
So maybe like 6pm central.
This guy and his job.
Yeah.
Wait, you have a job?
Unfortunately.
Why do you think like all the other coaches are available at 4 in the morning and...
I mean, Doki, I've been available to coach you.
You just hit me up when I'm literally like in bed, that Discord notification comes up.
Wait, you're a salaryman?
That's crazy.
Really?
No, I work remote these days so it's much easier.
So I can sneak some, you know...
It's not that bad.
I'm not like fucking out there doing a hard day's labor.
Dude, you're a salaryman and you're still kicking ass like that?
Yeah, exactly.
But I think I only beat the other salarymen.
Wait, the others are salarymen too?
Diaphone and Jibba Automatic.
Well, actually Automatic might be full-time concentration.
I know Diaphone has a job.
I think everybody else is like full-time.
Like professional stream player.
That's crazy, man.
That's nuts.
Well, that's why I was asking you BrawlPro.
You kind of trolled me.
I couldn't tell.
Are you a full-time streamer?
Basically.
See, I don't know.
Don't mix us up, dude.
We're your team.
I have very reduced hours nowadays.
So you can't justify it.
I got you.
Okay.
Literally, the stream does so well.
I literally can't justify working more.
No, I saw your stream numbers.
I was like, what the fuck?
That's why I was curious.
So Doki, we're talking because FGC streamers are poverty, right?
Oh, that's really odd.
I'm a full-time streamer.
It's actually a really unique thing.
BrawlPro had mad subs and I was like, what the hell?
It's so rare for a fighting game stream.
Fighting game streamers generally don't get that many subs.
There are some VTubers I hang out with and they're like, wait a minute.
There's people that full-time stream of fighting games?
What?
It's like, yeah.
You'd be surprised.
It's very rare.
This is why you got to take us to TwitchCon.
You have to take us to TwitchCon.
This is our full-time job.
Are you even going, Doki?
A form of me will be going.
We have some plans.
We have plans.
It will be great if we make it.
Well, you know, right now, I'm not going.
Wait, you're not?
What?
I'm debating it, but I have the World Warrior, the Capcom Cup qualification tournament that weekend.
And I'm kind of in the game for my region.
That's alright, because then we'll just choose the...
Do you know anybody that's top 100?
Yeah, I can get a substitute.
I can pull streams.
Wait, who's below Nephew's rank?
He's like, what, top 18th, right?
Who's ranked 17th?
Who's right above it?
Who's right above his rank?
Nephew is probably the best NA player that would be available right now, so...
I wouldn't worry about that.
The thing is, you guys has got to carry it.
In that format, it's all about you guys.
I just need to impart my lessons on you enough to give you the playbook so that it could be Joe Schmoe up the street as the coach position.
Can we get Punk?
Yeah, I can message Punk.
I'll publicly at Punk right now.
Are you friends with him?
Punk.
I can hit up Punk.
I don't know if...
He's friends with Nephew though, so he might not want to... No, but that's the best part because he's friends with him.
He wants to kick his ass.
Yeah.
Like, he wants to kick his ass.
That's what friends do.
No.
Doki, you've got to start retweeting his tweets now.
No, I'll just add him.
Okay, straight up, Adam.
Sounds good to me.
So, yeah.
I'm debating though, so I'm undecided.
I've got to figure that out real soon, so I'll let you guys know if that happens, and then we'll...
We have to get in first before we even...
We have to think about this.
I'm still a little bit confused because you guys said on Sunday there's some playoffs, so does every team go?
I'm still confused about the fucking format.
What happens on Sunday?
Or sorry, the finals?
Two teams are not going to TwitchCon.
Yeah.
The top four is going to TwitchCon.
Okay.
But like, so on Sunday, like two teams are going to get eliminated on Sunday.
Yes.
So whoever is at the lower bracket and they lose their lower bracket matches, they are fully eliminated.
Yeah.
So if it's double a limb, and if you get out, you're done.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Yeah.
So Sunday is...
So if we get seeded, that'd be sick.
I think like if we get the buy, then we don't have to...
We're automatically in, right?
I think so.
You say double a limb, so we all start in winners?
Yeah, we all start in winners.
Yep.
It's a regular bracket, but instead of people, it's teams.
It's a six-man bracket.
So the first round is going to be four teams, and then the second round, people get a buy, and the teams that win the first round will play the second, the team that got buy.
And then the other ones go to losers.
We basically have to win one game if we get the buy.
Yeah.
Dine got ahead of us?
Wait, what do you mean?
It looks like we're in third.
So Nephew, Dine, then our team.
Aw, damn.
Aw, 42 also, damn.
They got one more set win than us.
They got one set...
They just refreshed.
So we're on a three-rate tie with Phones' team.
Yeah.
Alright.
No, no, we're ahead of them.
We're not tied with them.
No, we're third.
We're cleanly third.
Wait, what?
After we refreshed again?
This sheet is like bugging out.
Yeah, this sheet is fucked up.
It's still being updated.
Yeah.
It's full.
We're going to be last place.
I'm still higher ranked than Gumi's team.
That's all that matters.
That's all I care about.
I care about my own division.
These set wins keep trickling in somehow, I don't know.
Someone said, I think the scoreboard is wrong.
Shine should have 39, but I don't know.
I mean, we can literally count it right now.
Recount!
I demand a recount!
Alright, guys.
Stop the count!
Chat, I know you guys are better at math than me.
Count this.
I'm posting the link right now.
Wait, is the link public?
Oh, shit.
I think it is.
I didn't post it.
I don't know.
I think it is.
It's read-only, so it should be fine.
Guys, here's the link.
I literally have it pulled up with the URL there.
Okay, count it and see if Seijan fucked up.
It's got to be the jam, man.
It's got to be him.
In the last slam, my team was like fifth in seeding and we got second in playoffs.
Yeah.
The Friday is really different.
Tomorrow, people are going to be training really hard tomorrow.
During Tekken, they were hard trained for our team after the first round robin.
I remember.
They were doing bot reviews and everything.
Yeah, we're going to audit.
We're auditing Seijan right now.
Get audited.
Oh, she's correct.
My chat's...
You guys are so good at math.
What the fuck?
They're going to find another win for somebody else if we keep auditing them.
I don't know.
I'm happy with third right now.
I ain't trying to push it.
Oh, because they 3-2 die as team.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Alright.
There's some things that I think I can... I mean, we'll go over in bot review, but I think there's a lot Who did you even lose to?
I lost to Huntress and I lost to Chun-Li.
Yeah, Huntress and...
What was the other one?
Wasn't it...
I beat Akuma.
Boxbox.
But I beat him in ranked.
I think you can definitely beat him tomorrow or Friday.
When you're fighting Boxbox, that's going to be more about remembering to respect the Modern.
You have to alter your strategy when you go up against them.
I think you know how to beat them.
You just have to remember to do it.
That's a huge thing with Modern.
It's a different game when you're playing an actual Modern player.
You can't drive as much.
You can't jump as much.
You've got to remember to slow it down.
I think you could definitely fade out some of his DPs and his DIs when you're in the corner.
He was getting a lot of mileage out of those two.
Oh, that's how I beat him in ranked.
I jump a lot more.
And then he just jumps.
I jump and he DPs the other way.
I'm like, yeah, free punish.
In my chat, we have Shine petitioning to Sajam to get rid of our points.
We're starting a nasty battle here.
Sajam said, Shine, you're so right.
We gave Team Brian F too many points.
Wait, what?
No!
We're gonna work petition.
We're fucking around.
I was like, wait, the Audit fucked us over?
That's what I'm saying.
Sometimes it's good to keep your head down.
No!
The Audit fucked us over instead.
Wait, no shot.
Did it really?
Nah, dude.
Sajam got V-Bucks.
Who's bribing him?
Nah, dude.
They gave him V-Bucks.
That would be funny, though.
Who's gonna audit the Auditors?
That's true.
Yeah, dude.
We need Auditors for the Auditors.
If we're dead last, we got nothing to lose.
Oh my god.
Third is the ultimate.
Keep your head down.
That's great because everybody's gonna everybody's gonna Vaude review.
Shine and Nephew's team.
They won't care about us.
We're in the middle of the pack.
Exactly.
They're all just gonna...
We just gotta keep cool.
Do our thing.
Low-key.
They're just gonna do drills for Shine and Nephew.
Exactly.
Yeah, everybody's gonna train for Nephew's team, so nobody's gonna realize that no one's gonna care about us.
Lily, Skara, Red-Rite, Ross, Huntress.
That team is actually... they're all kinda good at their level.
I mean, we were We basically won 4-0'd Shine's team.
It was just a coach match.
My chat's telling me Fumi was 2-3, not 3-2.
Oh, we got the auditors on.
Get the jam man on the phone.
Wait, for us or them?
What are you talking about?
Us versus Fumi.
I'm just saying what the chat's saying.
Don't listen to chat?
Okay, I don't know.
I was just...
We're grasping at straws here.
We speak, we're in big trouble.
Is this good for us or bad for us?
Imagine them listening to this chat.
We got it right.
But when it comes to Roy, I played him for the Tekken one and he plays just like he does in Tekken.
He plays like a dick, dude.
Just...
Just swap Roy and who's the first seed?
I could definitely fight that DJ, bro.
I swear.
Swap the Jamie and the DJ.
That's our petition.
That's our demand.
He just lets you come to you and that's it.
And I think with Keith, it's the easiest to abuse that playstyle.
Yeah, it is.
But like Brian was saying, poking is probably your best thing.
Round robin results, Fumi is 2-3 not 3-2.
Yeah, that's what my chat was saying.
For who?
For us or...
For her, like Fumi in general.
Instead of her going 3-2, she went 2-3.
That's what they're saying.
2...
3.
Oh...
Oh my god, the audit!
Are we gonna win the audit?
2...
Oh, dude, we're actually gonna win the audit.
No way.
Oh my god!
We won the audit!
Dude, we're winning coin flips and audits.
She has two wins only.
Yeah.
She only has two wins, but it says 3-2.
How come this isn't I'm kinda confused why this isn't automatically tracked.
Call them out right now.
I don't even...
52 years on the line!
Yes.
Dude, we really are the heel of this slam, dude.
Oh my god.
I don't even feel good about this.
Every tournament needs a heel, and I gladly accept it.
I'll accept it for the rest of us.
Is it?
Am I counting this right?
Yeah.
You know SageM doesn't have a job.
This is manual, dude.
Yeah, how is this...
I don't know.
Yo, Bb is on one right now.
Oh, he's 39!
Yes!
We did it!
We had a two-way tie!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, we're tied for six.
Yeah!
Dude, we are so bad.
Well, I don't feel that bad.
Do you?
Do you feel that bad?
I don't.
See, I knew math was important.
I knew that shit.
I wanna recap.
Sean, I didn't even mean to get into this battle with you, man.
No, I'm here for the integrity of the tournament.
Like...
There it is.
The rent is on the line, alright?
This is as grassroots as it can get.
But now we're tied for seconds.
Yeah!
Guys, don't get audited or this is gonna happen to you.
Do your taxes.
This never would've happened if Doki wasn't bad at math and said, chat, audit this now.
She would've never had the idea.
Well, her chat said it was good, okay?
How was your chat that said it?
My chat was not good at math either.
They reflect the streamer.
They're saying, die phone shine is messed up?
Oh my god.
Amor too?
Oh yeah.
Did they fuck up other stuff too?
I don't know.
I think things are falling apart.
Not a way to math.
Sage, we won't fuck your TOs, man.
Don't worry.
Bright Shield won two Amor.
So, I think that counts as a win.
So are we?
It's okay.
We already got second.
We don't need to do any more audits.
We already secured second place.
We opened the can of worms.
It's out of our control.
Oh boy.
All I know is tomorrow we're gonna see a whole different score.
Tomorrow we're at last place.
Yeah, we see ourselves at last place.
Someone has an offshore bank account.
A Cayman account somewhere with a lot of money.
Guys, this is why we have to do our taxes correctly.
It's why I hire someone.
Yeah, exactly guys.
This was fun.
This was good.
I think we all did well.
Really good.
GG's everybody.
GG's.
You guys are kicking a lot of ass.
I had a lot of fun.
Thank you.
Thank you coach for helping us.
Yeah, so tomorrow I'm gonna be available.
We can do non-dgen hours.
Thank you coach for being the moral compass of the team.
Yeah, he's like responsible.
He's literally the only person with the moral compass.
I have to go eat dinner so I don't get acid reflux because I'm old and go to bed and get ready for work.
Salary man and acid reflux.
This is crazy.
That's my plan for the evening.
Good job squad.
GG's everybody.
Have a good night.
Bye bye.
Have a great time.
GG's.
Bye bye.
Oh my god.
I am I'm actually really surprised how well I did today.
I was not I honestly was like okay I'm gonna win one game and that's it.
I was not confident at all.
Like everybody was grinding so much.
And like I don't know.
Like I'm not blocking.
So I'm happy that we did pretty well in the end.
And like we only lost our match ups because I trolled in the first game and I trolled in the first game and then on the first game I realized that I cannot be back seated like live.
Like my brain overloads during the tournament.
It's fine like when it's like regular rank but during the tournament like my mind actually over simulates cause I like don't know what to do.
And the king thing was not it.
I was very nervous.
First games I'm always very nervous on on the first game.
I'm always very nervous.
And like I'm also playing a Blanka match up for Gif is like the worst match up.
So like so like I was not I was not ready for like the Blanka match up cause like it's the worst match up for me and I don't play against a lot of Blankas in rank.
So I was really happy that in the end we only lost against the characters that were like Zeke Gif counters.
So I'm good with that.
I'm okay with that.
And we got second.
I'm really happy.
We were able to get second place in the end.
For the first day.
Anyway, fun team.
Fun games.
It took a while to like get into like the spirit of things because like I was super nervous in the beginning.
I was also like I was just full of hate.
Cause I was like cause rank makes me feel.
Rank really does make me feel dead inside.
But the team five is really good and that's all that matters.
I beat a plat player.
No, gold player.
So technically I belong in gold.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest up.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
I'll see you guys on Friday.
For real.
For more Street Fighter Sajam Slam.
I'm actually really surprised that Street Fighter retweeted my tweet.
I was not expecting that.
Hey I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Also thank you Justin for coaching me and watching my stream.
I really appreciate it.
I hope I made you proud Justin.
I don't know if you're still here.
But I hope I made Justin proud.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye.